Mir haben sie dann erzählt, es gibt dann auch noch ein geiles Computer-Museum in Cambridge und da gäbe es auch so eine Nachbildung eines Prozessors, wo auch jemand sich die Mühe gemacht hat, jeden Zustand mit LEDs anzuzeigen. Also wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, gibt es da auch so eine Art CPU, die langsam abläuft und wo du dann sozusagen Schritt für Schritt die kompletten CPU-Funktionalitäten nachschauen kannst. Das ist natürlich der totale Bitorgasmus.
Naja, ich gehe so richtig aus dem Leim, wenn die so Sachen ankündigen, die so mehr Richtung Trikorder gehen noch. Ich will das komplette Sensorpaket in diesen Devices haben, irgendwie so.
Ich find das Ding sieht gut aus.
Das heißt man muss den Inuktionsdödel...
Ja, ist auf jeden Fall Hardcore. Na ja, also wenn man da mal so ein C64 mit nachbaut. Oder halt noch was einfacheres.
Ja, wer auf meinem Server mitspielen will, kann sich auch vertrauensvoll an mich auf Twitter werden, wenn die alte Crew, haben sich jetzt alle mittlerweile andere Server gesucht, weil ich jetzt ein Jahr lang mal nicht gespielt habe.
Was kann man auf deinem Server teureres machen als auf anderen?
Nix. Nix, aber man muss nix bezahlen, ist korrekt gehostet.
Korrekt, gefällt mir.
Ja, melde ich mich mal bei dir.
Ist die Sektion Eat Your Own Dog Feedback jetzt beendet?
Ja, jetzt können wir uns überlegen, womit wir weitermachen wollen. Hat jemand einen Wunsch?
Weil wir ja gerade bei Spiele waren, knüpfe ich mal an. Und zwar hat man einer der älteren Sendungen, ja, habe ich schon mal, ist schon ein Jahr her oder vielleicht schon zwei, weiß nicht mehr, so ein kleines Puzzlespiel auf iOS beworben, das hieß The Sequence. Genau, Hoke merkt ja mal, wenn ich das TH nicht lethbege.
Da ist ja gar keins drin. Ja, was ist das?
Na, es gab halt den ersten Teil, jetzt gibt es seit einem Monat oder ein bisschen länger den zweiten Teil, The Sequence 2.
Würdest du mir das als Klingelton einsprechen?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie viel Level es hat, aber es hat ziemlich viele. Ich gucke mal kurz. Also ich bin jetzt bei Level 44 und es ist so das, ich bin am Ende vom ersten Drittel, also es könnte schon so 120 Level haben, oder so in dem Dreh. Und ich hänge jetzt bei Level 44 ab, schon seit 3-4 Tagen schaffe ich diesen einen Level, nicht? Und ja, wer ihm das Sequenz gefallen hat, dem wird das Sequenz 2 noch viel mehr gefallen, weil es wieder genauso cool ist, ein bisschen anders, hat andere Mechaniken, so ein bisschen, aber ich würde sagen, es ist auch ein bisschen schwerer als das erste. Also wenn man das erste nicht gespielt hat, dann sollte man vielleicht nicht gleich mit dem hier anfangen. Also da sind wirklich Dinge dabei, da überlegste erstmal eine Weile. Und es ist immer schön auch eingeführt, dass die einzelnen Module, die so Sachen durch die Gegend schieben, die werden immer schon erklärt. Also das Spiel erklärt sich sehr gut selbst. Also es macht wirklich sehr viel Spaß. Kostet 2,20 Euro oder sowas.
Und wie ist das, wenn man das länger nicht gespielt hat? Weiß man das dann trotzdem immer noch alles?
Nee, ich hab das auch schon mal gemacht. Wenn ich jetzt das erste nochmal spielen müsste, dann musst du, weil teilweise sind die Lösungen auch so komplex, die kannst du dir eigentlich nicht merken, dann musst du dich nochmal so richtig reinversetzen, warum das jetzt nicht geht und du das machen musst. Dann fällt an, nee, das geht auch nicht, deswegen musst du das machen. Also da muss ich dann teilweise wieder voll so reinarbeiten. Also ich glaube, ich würde das erst jetzt auch nicht so schnell nochmal lösen können. Also da... Am Anfang hast du so, da schaffst du so 2, 3, 4, 5 Level am Tag. Und am Ende hatte ich dann wirklich 2, 3, 4, 5 Tage pro Level, weil du wirklich so lange brauchst, bis du das geschneitest, wie das jetzt mal gehen soll, weil die wirklich immer komplexer werden, die Rätsel. Und ja, aber es ist wirklich super gut. Gab es, glaube ich, damals auch sehr viel Feedback, dass das wirklich ein guter Tipp war. Deswegen jetzt habe ich mich voll gefreut, nachdem ich gelesen habe, dass es jetzt den zweiten Teil gibt, habe ich mir den auch gleich ohne doll nachzudenken sofort geklickt, weil so viel Spaß für 2,20 Euro, das ist unschlagbar. Kann ich nur empfehlen, wer Langeweile hat.
Zum Thema Langeweile, den Kopf gerade noch aufgeflesht nachträglich, ist immer noch spielererelevant, nämlich in Minecraft HDL, wo sich jemand hingesetzt hat und quasi Schaltungs-Synthese für Redstone Circuits gebaut hat. Also das, womit du FPGAs quasi beschickst. Und das generiert ihr dann aber Minecraft Redstone Circuits. Oh man, da war gerade ein Link im Chat. Ich wechsel ihn einfach nochmal rein, falls jemand das nicht mitbekommt. Großes Kino.
Sind das die CPU-Designer der Zukunft? Weil die nämlich schon in 3D bauen, weil die heutigen CPUs, die sind ja schon so ein bisschen in der Höhe, aber noch nicht so richtig, oder? Also ist doch alles noch eine Belichtung oder so, oder wie auch immer die das machen. Und dann können die das sozusagen auch noch nach oben.
Ich hätte ja auch noch hier, weil ich ja letztes Mal wegen diesen Bluetooth-Kopfhörern, war ich das, der die Themenkarte aufgemacht hatte. Ich habe mir in der Zwischenzeit schon welche gekauft, tatsächlich. Und zwar deswegen, weil ich mir auch noch das passende Endgerät dazu geklickt habe.
Ich bin nicht gerade vorhin vor der Sendung noch gesagt, dass du Kabel so gerne magst?
Ja, das hat er nur ganz leise zu mir gesagt.
Ja, ich habe mir zwei gekauft. Ich habe ja im Urlaub, wie gesagt, meinen iPod Shuffle verloren. Mir hat mittlerweile ein ehemaliger Freak Show-Hörer, der mir aber noch auf Twitter followt.
Ein ehemaliger Freak Show-Hörer?
Der hört jetzt andere Podcasts. Ach so. Jetzt können wir über ihn herziehen hier. Der hat mir seinen iPod Shuffle vermacht. Dann hatte ich aber immer noch keine Kopfhörer. Dann habe ich mir einmal kabelgebundene Kopfhörer gekauft, die ich schon seit Jahren und Jahrzehnten kaufe und immer wieder kaufen werde, solange es sie noch gibt.
Welche denn? Wo musst du die am laufenden Meter neu kaufen?
Die gehen nie kaputt, ich verliere sie, wenn dann. Ich habe bisher zwei verloren. Ich glaube, zwei Mal auf sie reisen tatsächlich. Ja, was denn? Warte, ich paste es ja schon in den Link, in den Chat. Diese Kopfhörer da, klickt mal da drauf. Funktioniert der Link? Ja, doch, müsste er, ne? Von, wie heißen die? Sound Magic? Genau. Die haben mal in irgendeinem Review in einer Reihe irgendwie Preise gewonnen und ich finde die auch immer noch sehr gut für einfach so ganz einfache, in-ear Kopfhörer ohne viel drum herum und enthaltbar haben will. Die kann ich sehr empfehlen, klingen auch gut. Gibt es auch mit irgendwelchen Fernbedienungen und so weiter. Ich habe die aber ohne alles, einfach nur Kopfhörer. Genau, und dann habe ich mir in so einem leichten Rap...
Schön, die gibt es in zwei Varianten, kabelgebunden und mit Kabel. Was meinen Sie denn damit?
Ja, du weißt ja, wenn Amazon Dinge nicht selber verkauft, sondern... Und dann habe ich nach der letzten Freak Show so einen kleinen Rappel bekommen, getrieben von der Schaffelarmut. Und weil ich den ja immer beim Sport benutze, für Musik hören, dachte ich mir, vielleicht muss ich doch jetzt mal ins 21. Jahrhundert springen. Und habe mir mal testhalber so eine Apple Watch geklickt. Mit GSM und so. Nee, dafür habe ich mir dann halt die Bluetooth. Ja, alle Lichter an. Also die Preislichter nicht alle an, aber die Feature-Lichter.
Also schon so eine Alu-Watch, aber halt mit LTE.
Rate. Pink. Roségold, nein natürlich. Hackerschwarz. Genau, die kommt jetzt aber erst am 2. bis 9. Oktober angeblich. Und die Kopfhörer habe ich jetzt aber schon.
Groß oder klein?
Ja, ich habe mir die große geklickt. Und jetzt bin ich ein bisschen sorgenvoll, weil ich habe ja nicht so die dicksten Arme. Vielleicht kann ich mal deine kurz umlegen.
Ich habe ja auch gehört, die neue kleine ist ja größer als die alte große.
Nein, der Bildschirm ist die sichtbare Fläche des Displays.
Ja, aber der Formfaktor ist auch sehr wichtig. Kann ich deine mal kurz vielleicht gucken, wie verloren mein schmaler Arm darunter aussieht?
Aber ich glaube, das wird täuschen. Schmal ist der gar nicht, Hucke. Auch noch nicht.
Ach so, Hucke, man trägt doch jetzt Uhren nicht ums Handgelenk, sondern vor der Brust. Das haben wir doch der letzten Sendung schon geklärt.
Na wie Flavor Flav.
Ach so, wie geht das zu?
Das ist deine erste Uhr, ja?
Ach so, das erste Armband dieser Art. Das ist nicht dein Ernst. Das ist auch das Teure, ne?
Ja, kann man schon mal machen.
Das ist die Große?
Das ist die Große, wobei, also die andere, die Neue, da kann ich jetzt nur Mutmaßen, wirkt flacher und breiter, weil es auch ist, wenn auch nur ein Millimeter.
Ja, ich hab da auf der Webseite stand halt die Arm-Handgelenk-Umfänge und mein Handgelenk war in der Range und jetzt bin ich beruhigt. Okay, muss ich nicht nochmal umenden an die Bestellung.
Ja, das wird schon passen. Das ist eher Geschmacksfrage, wie groß man es denn so haben will. Ich meine, der große Bildschirm macht natürlich total Sinn. Ich hab mich noch nicht so richtig dazu durchringen können, da jetzt auf irgendeinen Kauf-Button zu klicken, weil ich halt, erstens sind die doch nochmal deutlich teurer geworden.
Da ist noch eine Stufe zu Ende.
Ich hätte schon ganz gern die teure Variante, wenn schon, denn schon.
Also die nicht aus Alu, sondern aus Stahl?
Ja, einfach mal Safir Glas, keine Kratzer mehr im Glas und so. Weil ich hau das Ding dann doch irgendwie immer ordentlich überall gegen und hab dann doch immer irgendwo eine Riefe drin. Auch wenn das wirklich wieder Jammern auf hohem Niveau ist.
Ja, ich wollte auf jeden Fall GSM haben, damit ich irgendwie dann tatsächlich dieses Feature hab von wegen...
Das heißt, wir können uns beide eine kaufen und du kannst mir so ein paar Links irgendwie überhelfen.
Ja, Letty, das geht schon. Also das Armband ist halt für Tims speckige...
Muskulöse Arben.
Ich hab eigentlich nur ein bisschen Stänken.
Muskulöses Handgelenk, ne?
Muskellos! Zwei Punkte machen den Unterschied. Ja, genau. Und die Kopfhörer, die ich mir dazu geklickt hab, das sind die Bose Sound Sport heißen die. Und eigentlich nur aus dem Grund, weil die in verschiedensten Reviews jetzt so klanglich als auch sportlich irgendwie besonders gut geeignet waren. Angeblich. Ich hab sie jetzt auch schon mal getestet mit meinem iPhone. Das war vielleicht jetzt das erste Mal so mit dem Telefon beim Sport.
Da ich jetzt ja auch ein iPhone X habe und... Dieses iPhone halt zum Gesicht reinhalten. Es passte natürlich nicht in mein... Also ich habe mich jetzt durchgeruhmt und beim Laufen angefangen Podcast zu hören und hatte so eine, wie heißt das denn so, was man sich im Bauch schnallt, so Gürteltasche. Und da passt so das Telefon natürlich gleich gar nicht rein. Jetzt brauche ich irgendwie eine größere Tasche, nur damit ich irgendwie Podcast hören kann. Beim Laufen.
Naja, das ist bei mir jetzt hoff... also ich bin mal gespannt. Ich habe jetzt ja wie gesagt den iPod Shuffle und die alte Lösung immer noch als Backup. Aber jetzt habe ich auch sozusagen die Zukunft auf dem Weg.
Ja, vielleicht werde ich auch doch den Rückschritt wagen und einfach den iPod Shuffle dann mit Podcast bestücken.
Ja, das sind übrigens hier, ich habe mal den Link noch zu den Kopfhörern reingetan, falls das irgendjemand später interessiert. Ähm, ja.
Und die hast du jetzt auch schon getestet?
Also man sieht so ein bisschen aus wie ferngesteuert, weil diese Plastik Schnupsies halt dann so ein bisschen abstehen wie bei hier Frankenstein nur an den Ohren. Aber wie gesagt, so in den verschiedensten Reviews, die ich so gelesen habe, meinten halt, ja, meinten die Leute, die halten gut, sind irgendwie ganz gut, schweiß- und so weiter resistent und klingen gut und die Konkurrenten oder andere Modelle, die dann auch hier im Kommentarbereich genannt wurden, diese Jabra, Sport und so. Habe ich mir auch angeguckt, aber irgendwie klang die jetzt erstmal ganz sympathisch und sind sie auch. Also bei mir halten die tatsächlich auch auf dem Laufband.
Auf dem Laufband?
Ja, da ist ja halt am meisten, ich habe auch nicht so eine super fluffig gepolsterte Laufschuhe, sondern...
Warum hat denn diese Tasche einen HDMI-Anschluss, oder sehe ich gerade irgendwas schief?
Die Tasche hat einen HDMI-Anschluss?
Das ist doch USB in sehr groß, oder?
Der hat aber hier so eine abgewinkelten...
Das... was ist das?
Das Mikro-USB, oder?
Wie, davon gibt es eine Ladetasche auch?
Ja, ich hab nur auf den Link geklickt von dir.
Echt?
Ach so, hier steht es mit Transport-ETUI mit Ladefunktion.
Ach so, ich hab nicht die mit Ladefunktion. Wenn ich auf den Link klicke, komme ich hier hin und da ist kein Lade-ETUI.
Ja, wahrscheinlich, ja sorry. Vielleicht habe ich irgendwo weitergeklickt, deswegen war ich mal irritiert.
Na ja, das gibt es da unten, genau. Das gibt es als Extra-Zubehör.
Aber wie sind die denn ge... Ach so, da ist eine Übersicht, wie die gewinkelt sind.
Also es gibt da auch, wie ich festgestellt habe, einen riesigen Markt. Alle springen da jetzt gerade total drauf auf. Aber zum Beispiel die Beats, die irgendwie auch so in ihr mäßig waren, die sind halt zum Beispiel nicht schweißresistent etc. Also es gibt da wohl auch noch eine sportliche Variante, aber die, die wir gesehen haben, die relativ slick aussahen und nicht so teuer waren, die sind halt eigentlich nicht primär für Sport, sondern nur so für Pokémon spielen.
Wie meinst du diese Power Beats?
Ja, ich weiß nicht, wann ist die? Hatten wir nicht letztes Mal noch andere? Weil das sind ja die sportlichen. Ich dachte, wir hatten noch mal welche ohne diese Bügel gesehen.
Diese Bügel willst du eigentlich haben, wenn es jetzt wirklich Sport ist, weil die dann irgendwie auch halten, ganz kompromisslos.
Ja, aber irgendwie diese Beats-Kopfhörer, die haben immer in ihren Reviews so relativ, wie soll man das charmant sagen, nicht so wohlwollende Kommentare bezüglich des Sounds.
Naja, ich meine, das ist ja dann immer Geschmacksfrage.
Ja, aber wenn das alle Reviews sagen, dann...
Dann nicht, ja. Aber die Frage ist, hast du alle Reviews gelesen?
Also, ich bin doch auch ein Nerd. Ich grase das Internet dann schon relativ gründlich ab.
Ich bin ja echt damit überlegen, ob ich mir diese Aftershocks mal zulege zum Laufen, weil die halt auch fürs Fahrradfahren ganz interessant sind.
Was sind Aftershocks?
Das ist auch Bluetooth, aber die sind halt nicht gegen ihr, sondern diese Bone-Kondakte.
Ach, das ist mir zu freaky.
Ja, das ist freaky, aber es ist halt auch irgendwie ganz geil, wenn du alles um dich wunderschöpfst.
I think you're freaky and I like it a lot.
Ja. Hast du es denn schon mal ausprobiert? Und ist es geil? Weil die Tonqualität ist ja höchstwahrscheinlich nicht so geil wie jetzt richtige Kopfhörer.
Ähm, nee, ich würde sie halt nicht zum Musikhören wahrscheinlich nehmen. Das ist jetzt also für Podcasts hören, vielleicht ist es auch für Musikhören gut, weiß ich nicht.
Ich habe halt Reviews gelesen, wo es explizit um so die besten Sport-Bluetooth-Kopfhörer ging. Da hatten sie auch so Bone Conducting, ich weiß nicht, ob es jetzt die waren. Und da war dann immer das Kommentar, ja, also soundmäßig können die nicht so mithalten, aber wenn man jetzt nicht unbedingt da drauf den größten Wert legt, dann sind die schon auch ganz gut. Und die kann man auch beim Schwimmen dann sogar verwenden? Ich habe schon Leute gesehen im Swimmingpool mit Kopfhörern. Und da würde mich auch mal interessieren.
Also Wasserdichte gibt es ja auch, ne? Also die sind IP55.
Also nicht so richtig, ja.
Naja. Also die 5 heißt, dass die schon eine halbe Stunde Wasser eigentlich aushalten müssten. Ich mich jetzt nicht ganz täusche. Gucken wir mal kurz nach.
Naja, aber für im Schwimmbad so sportlich schwimmen, dann ja wohl ja nicht so richtig.
Die Frage ist doch aber auch, so weil ihr wegen der Uhr stimmt. Ich war gerade beim Telefon und wollte gerade fragen, wo du das Telefon hinklemmst, wenn du schwimmst.
Eine Minute pro Square Meter vor at least 15 Minutes.
Also IP55 ist Schutz gegen Strahlwasser aus beliebigen Winkel. Was sagt man das jetzt eigentlich? Dauerndes Untertauchen.
Oh, ich will 6K. Geh mal weiter runter nochmal. 6K Schutz gegen starkes Strahlwasser und erhöhtem Druck, spezifisch für Straßenfahrzeuge.
Die kriegst du aber nicht mehr als Bluetooth.
Ist das auch gegen Wasserwerfer?
Schutz gegen Wasser bei Hochdruck, Dampfstrahlreinigung.
Wasserwerferresistent. Ja, also ich kann dann sozusagen im Oktober mal berichten, wie es in dieser schönen neuen Apple Watch und Bluetooth-Welt zugeht. Ja, aber ich muss sagen, zum Beispiel, was auch ein Kommentar war in den ganzen Reviews, dass für die Beats, dass die ja diesen Apple-Chip für das ultrachnelle Pairing und so weiter verwenden und dass irgendwie das halt das Tollste dann eigentlich an den Beats ist, dass die wie die AirPods halt sich ohne Probleme pairen. Oder wie funktioniert das Pairing da, dieser spezielle... Bei den AirPods?
Weiß man nicht. Du machst den Deckel auf, das Telefon sagt, das sind Pots, du sagst Yes und dann geht's los. Du machst gar nichts eigentlich.
Also weil die Bose-Dinger, die muss ich jetzt natürlich einmal so pairen, pairen, aber jetzt immer wenn ich die einschalte, sind die dann auch sofort am Start und gepaert. Also das ist jetzt auch kein großer Hässel. Das fand ich ganz sympathisch, weil da hat man ja immer die größte Angst bei diesem Bluetooth. Das P-Ring.
Tja, also es gibt hier auch so IPX8 waterproof und so weiter, aber dann funktioniert halt Bluetooth nicht mehr. Von daher, bisschen pointless.
Aber hast du dann die Musik auf dem Kopfhörer? Also hat der internen...
Speicher, klar. Das ist dann so quasi wie dein Shuffle, halt nur so mit dem üblichen Beladeproblem.
Na ich bin nämlich vor Kurzem im Schwimmbad unterwegs gewesen, und dann plötzlich blinkte es so neben mir unter Wasser. Und ich dachte mir so, hä, what the fuck? Und dann habe ich den Typen mal von oben sozusagen angeschaut und er hat sich so Kopfhörer auf, der fröhlich vor sich hin blinkte.
So, next. Jetzt haben wir schon über Apple Watch geredet, was ja hier schon berichtet. Hier haben wir ein bisschen unsere Themen weggemacht. Wollen wir nochmal ein bisschen auf unser Keynote-Review eingehen? Was noch so war? Wer fängt an? Ich weiß gar nicht, habe ich irgendwas da von hier hingeschrieben? Du hast das hier hingeschrieben, oder?
Oder Hucke?
Oder Roddy?
Ich nicht.
Roddy ist nicht da. Nee, das mit dem iPhone hast du da hingeschrieben, Dennis, oder mit dem Band?
Nee, ich habe nur immer meinen Namen davor geschrieben. Was für ein Band? Ach so, das habe ich vorhin erwähnt. Ja, also, was ihr in der letzten Sendung nicht erwähnt habt, weil ich hab den nicht vorhin gehört, weil ich hab mich vorbereitet. Wow. Ich wollte das mal anerkannt wissen. Was ihr nicht erwähnt habt, ist... Soll ich noch einen Keks essen? Dann hast du mir welche übrig. Ihr habt nicht erwähnt, dass das neue iPhone XS, so heißt das nämlich, Letty. Okay, ich übe auch immer. Dass das jetzt hier einen besseren LTE-Empfang hat. Und zwar, weil es eine weitere Antenne hat.
Darf ich dir mal...
Ja, testing, testing, one, two, one, two. Genau, es hat nämlich jetzt 4x4-Mimo. Und das kann man auch sehen unten am Phone, da regen sich ja manche Leute auf, weil es hat jetzt links nur noch 3 Löcher für den Lautsprecher und rechts 5, links nur noch 3, weil daneben jetzt nämlich ein so ein Antennenbandstreifen in Design zu erkennen ist. Dadurch ist wohl der bessere Empfang möglich. Dem widersprechend aber kann man jetzt im Netz, im großen Internet lesen, dass viele Leute sich wo beschweren, dass sie schlechteren Empfang mit dem XS-Telefon haben. Da muss man mal gucken, wie sich das so ausbalanciert, welche Seite da gewinnen wird, von wegen besserer Empfang. Und manche sagen, nee, ist aber genau gerade nicht so. Da muss ich wahrscheinlich noch auszetteln, dass die sich da einig sind. Oder vielleicht müssen wir auch wieder Updates nachspielen. Das wäre nicht das erste Mal. Aber ja, ich habe bis jetzt von besserem Empfang nicht so viel gemerkt, weil man ja vor allem zu Hause auch immer hier WLAN-Calling hat. Das merkt man ja dann eh nicht so. Und ich bin ja eh O2-Opfer, da hat man ja sowieso immer schlechten Empfang. Um das jetzt mal rauszulassen, ich werde wechseln, ihr Penner. Ja, wirklich, ich schnauze voll. Aber vielleicht muss ich ja gar nicht wechseln, dann kann mein ultra-L-cheap O2 0 Euro pro Monat Vertrag behalten. Und kann auf das Dual-SIM-Feature zurückgreifen. Ich weiß nur noch nicht, wie man das so genau regelt. Und noch ist es ja auch gar nicht in der Software freigeschaltet. Ich hab vorhin im Netz gelesen, in Deutschland gibt es jetzt iOS 12.1 Beta. Und da gibt es wohl schon die Screens, da geht das wohl schon so halb. Und da sind Leute wohl schon am ausprobieren. Aber ich weiß noch nicht, wie das überhaupt mit dieser eSIM ist und wer das verkauft und wie man das kriegt und wie da so die Deals sind und so. Aber die Hauptidee ist doch, dass man wohl seine feste Telefonnummer auf der karte, auf der physikalischen behält, oder? Und die eSIM immer schön wechselt, weil man will ja das in der eSIM haben, was man oft wechselt und seine Telefonnummer behält man ja. Das heißt, die wechselt man nicht oft, also nimmt man die als Karte.
Nee, glaub ich nicht.
Würdest du andersrum machen?
Also wie ich's machen würde, ist jetzt nicht entscheidend. Ich würde natürlich sagen, sowieso nur noch eSIM und man kriegt nur noch mal und weg mit diesem blöden Chip und was soll dieser Quatsch. Ich meine, diese SIM-Karte ist ja quasi so die Diskette des 21. Jahrhunderts.
Ja, aber das Schöne ist, man kann die dann rausnehmen und woanders reinstecken. Kann man die eSIM so wechseln von einem Telefon zu einem anderen und auch wieder zurück und so? Geht das?
Also es gibt jetzt nichts, was dagegen sprechen würde, dass du auch ein anderes Telefon über diesen Weg provisionieren kannst. Wie sehr dir dann die Anbieter da einen Strick draus drehen und versuchen, da irgendwie ihre Grenzen auszuloten, das ist klar. Aber die eSIM ist natürlich viel befreiender, weil du eben dieses ganze Formatproblem passierst rein und dann kaufst du dir einen SIM-Stanzer, aber Amazon und fragst dich ja auch, wo du eigentlich lebst, das ist ja wirklich wie in 80er Jahren, wo wir unsere Disketten gelocht haben.
Ja, geil, oder?
Guck mal, doppelte Kapazität. Nur muss ich das erstmal einspielen, dieser ganze Glimp. Also es läuft ja derzeit so, wenn ich es richtig sehe, wenn du jetzt eine eSIM mit der Watch provisionieren willst, dann kriegst du ja so einen QR-Code. Das heißt, du bekommst von der Telekom so einen Zettel mit dem QR-Code. Und während du dann halt deine Watch einrichtest, scanst du dann im Setup-Prozess diesen QR-Code ab. Und in diesem QR-Code ist quasi so das Aktivierungstoken für eine SIM-Karte, für einen, in dem Fall deinen existierenden Vertrag. Und dann gibt es ein Protokoll, was dieses Setup-Programm mit dem Telekom-Server spricht. Und jemand hatte da auch schon mal Einblicke. Telekom hat da irgendwelche HP-Systeme, die früher mal Abrechnungssysteme waren und jetzt so in so eSIM-Provisionierungssysteme überführt worden sind. Und mit denen sprichst du dann halt und die geben dir dann quasi so digital signiert dieses, okay, darfst du benutzen. Hier ist der Code und dann lädt die Watch sich das halt in dieses Secure-Enclave mit rein und dann existiert in dieser Secure-Enclave quasi derselbe Code, den du sonst auf der SIM-Karte hättest. Und ich vermute mal mit diesem ganzen Scheiß, mit diesem ganzen Java-Gedöns, was da drin ist und all dem ganzen Bim-Bim und Spy-Software und was weiß ich. So und damit ist das Ding provisioniert. Derzeit ist das ja quasi nur so ein zweites Device zu einem bereits aktivierten Account, aber im Prinzip läuft es dann in Zukunft darauf hinaus, dass wenn du halt jetzt sagst, hier Dollar Anbieter, ich möchte gerne zu ihnen wechseln, ich brauche aber keine SIM-Karte, dann kriegst du von denen quasi auch nur ein QR-Code. Das heißt, du schließt den Vertrag ab und kriegst halt auch nur so ein Aktivierungstoken anstatt dieser SIM-Karte und dann wird die SIM-Karte quasi heruntergeladen. Eigentlich ist das ja eben der Unterschied zwischen CD-Ausliefern und Download.
Also ich stelle mir vor, dass wenn ich demnächst einkaufe, gehe ich hier beim Späte, dass ich dem Typen beim Späte sage, ey, hier, gib mir mal hier so eine 20 Gigabyte eSIM. Dann gibt er mir die und wenn ich die wegverbraten habe, dann hole ich mir die nächste, dass ich das sozusagen so... So könnte ich mir das gut vorstellen.
Ja, das heißt, du brauchst ja nicht immer wieder eine neue Identität und immer wieder eine neue Telefonnummer. Nur um mehr Daten zu haben, dann nimmst du halt mehr Daten auf diesen Vertrag auf, wenn du überhaupt noch eine Bekennung hast.
Ich will ja gar keinen Vertrag haben eigentlich.
Ja, also, dass du jetzt gar keinen Vertrag... Also da entwickelt sich ja die Dystopie unserer Gesellschaft jetzt nicht unbedingt in diese Richtung.
Du kriegst jetzt auch nicht einfach so Sim-Sommer unter deinem Ticket.
Ja, das ist ja mit Telefonnummer. Ich will ja nur eine Daten-E-SIM haben.
Ändert ja nichts an der Tatsache, dass sie hinter dir her sein wollen. Ich finde das nicht, aber die finden das. Ja, gerade der Herr Ahrens macht doch auch ein Bitcoin und so. Also so eine Leute hier.
Ja, ich würde das cool finden, wenn ich beim Späti hier sage, ey, Ali, gib mir mal noch hier so eine 10 Gig, ach, mach mal heute eine 15 Gig.
Was heißt beim Späti, das klickst du hier halt auf irgendeiner SIM-Punkt, VURU irgendwie.
SIM-RU, genau.
Ja, letztendlich eine SIM-Karte irgendwo, wo Chimmin Flower Power, Network Enterprises runter. Und dann hast du deinen Kram. Jetzt natürlich erstmal die Frage, wie geht jetzt die Telekom an diesen neuen iPhone, ESE im Markt ran? Ja, und alle anderen. Also Vodafone und Telekom sind ja die einzigen, die eigentlich in Deutschland das anbieten, und sonst gibt es ja auch nur noch O2 und die ja...
Die Watch jetzt, aber ESE müssten vielleicht noch einfach Male machen, oder nicht? Oder meinst du, die können das nicht?
Apple hat gesagt, dass sie mit Telekom und Vodafone ESE machen. Das war in den Slides und so weiter. Und O2 knickt, glaube ich, gerade ein, dass sie jetzt irgendwie auch Watch machen wollen. Und so haben jetzt irgendwie eingesehen, dass sie sich dem nicht widersetzen können. Beziehungsweise haben wir jetzt endlich mal einen Anbieter gefunden, der dann halt einen entsprechenden Provisionierungs-Server aufsetzen muss, weil die müssen ja dafür auch Infrastruktur schaffen. Das kannst du ja nicht einfach nur so beschließen. Sondern du musst ja dann quasi auch diesen Code ausliefern können. Das muss getestet und sicher sein. Oder vielleicht muss es nicht sicher sein, sondern die brauchen da halt irgendwie doller Lösung. Genau. So, jetzt gibt es natürlich solche und solche Verträge bei der Telekom. Interessant ist natürlich für viele Leute gerade der Unlimited-Vertrag. Da wollen sie aber für eine SIM-Karte pro Monat 30 Euro haben. Das heißt, wenn du deine Apple Watch mit dem Vertrag machst, dann zahlst du 30 Euro im Monat, damit deine Uhr noch mal ein paar Bats übertragen kann.
Anläutert aber.
Na ja, super. Aber was willst du mit der Uhr groß an Daten übertragen? Das kann nicht sein. Das sind auch wieder so amerikanische Verhältnisse, wo dir so SIM-Karten für absurde Preise verkauft werden, bevor du überhaupt nur das erste Bit übertragen hast. Vollkommen Gaga. Na ja, das kennen wir ja schon den ganzen Spaß. Aber so funktioniert das mit den eSims. Und ich denke mal, wir werden in absehbarer Zukunft, wird es halt so sein, dass du, wenn du so ein Xs, 10s, was auch immer hast, also ein eSim-fähiges Telefon, dass du eben sagen kannst, ich will keine physikalische SIM haben, schick mir einfach ein Barcode. Und dann druckt dir dir im Laden, kommt dann der Barcode aus dem Drucker raus, den nimmst du mit nach Hause und setzt dein Telefon auf. Und fertig ist die Laube. Und im Prinzip kannst du mit dem selben Barcode dann auch noch weitere Telefone mit initialisieren. Du musst ja jedes Gerät neu holen oder keine Ahnung. Das wird sich dann einpendeln. Aber dieses ganze SIM-Karten verschicken wird irgendwann auch ein Ende haben. Nicht so schnell.
Und SIM-Karten schnitzen.
Und SIM-Karten schnitzen. Heißt aber auch, dass sich quasi derzeit alles noch so darstellt, dass du eben den SIM-Kartenslot benutzt. Der eSIM-Kartenslot ist frei. Aber eigentlich möchtest du lieber deine dauerhafte, langfristige Vertragsgeschichte als eSIM haben, damit du den anderen Slot frei hast, um dir eben mal noch mal so eine beliebige Reisekarte da reinzutackern.
Du ziehst dir das genau andersrum. Ich will ja nicht andauernd, wenn ich im Urlaub bin, da irgendwie mit einer nadeligen Dinger hinnehmen.
Du wirst lange, lange, lange Zeit...
Woanders kein eSIM kriegen, meinst du? Ist natürlich auch ein Argument.
Vorteil ist natürlich, und das Ding ist, ich meine, ich verstehe auch gar nicht, warum das Ding nur Dual-SIM hat. Ich meine, wenn es eSIM hat, wie viele eSIMs kriegen sie da rein? Da ist ja jetzt nicht so... Da ist ja nicht so viel Daten drauf. Die könnten ja auch mal locker 10 eSIMs unterstützen.
Die Frage ist doch, warum bekommt nur China die Möglichkeit, zwei SIM-Karten reinzulegen?
Weil da eSIMs wahrscheinlich noch nicht zugelassen sind.
Weil da die Überwachungstechnik nämlich fehlt.
Ja, aber wenn du... Dann hättest du das Problem... Hättest du vielleicht trotzdem das Problem, dass du deine eigene SIM und die aus dem Ausland halt leichter hin und her tauschen kannst.
Eigentlich wollen wir das China-Phone haben, mit zwei. Also ich sehe gar keinen Grund, warum so ein Telefon nicht beliebig viele SIM-Karten gleichzeitig vorhalten kann. Warum ist jetzt auf Dual...
Vorhalten geht wahrscheinlich schon, aber gleichzeitig benutzen die ihn nicht wegen Antennaproblems, die können ja nicht unendlich viele Karten gleichzeitig abfragen, oder?
Was?
Wieso?
Was hat das mit der Antenne zu tun?
Ich dachte, die sind doch beide gleichzeitig aktiv oder nicht?
Ja und, wo soll das jetzt das Problem sein?
Ich kenne mich auch nicht so aus, aber ich dachte, dass das nicht unendlich skaliert mit wenig Antennen oder einer. Okay, inzwischen sind es ja ein paar mehr.
Du meinst, dass das Telefon nicht in der Lage ist, auf verschiedenen Bändern gleichzeitig zu kommunizieren?
Nicht mit zehn Zugängen, sondern jetzt halt mit zweien.
Kann natürlich sein, dass es da eine Limitierung gibt. Da habe ich noch gar nicht drüber nachgedacht. Aber ist ja egal, also man könnte ja auch mehrere vorhalten, aber immer nur zwei aktiv haben oder so. Aber da hält dir den Vorteil, du fährst halt in den Urlaub und dann kannst du dir quasi deine ESM schon vorher runterladen und dann ist die schon aktiv, wenn du in das Land reinkommst.
Vor allem kannst du dann so ein Programm haben, was automatisch immer das billigste auswählt und dann da die Daten holt. So wie vorher diese Vorwahlautomaten an einem Telefon, die immer den günstigsten Tarif berechnet haben. Kannst du dich erinnern?
Ja, kann ich mich erinnern. Und genau das wollen natürlich die ganzen Anteils verhindern.
Schon klar.
Das werden sie auch nicht befreit.
Man muss einfach mal nur coole Angebote machen und dann verhindern sie es auch. Nämlich nehmen sie einfach mal coole Preise machen.
Tja.
Aber man kann ja dann vielleicht auch demnächst billig billig eSims aus dem Ausland sich einkaufen und dann, wenn man eh nur Daten benutzt. Wobei dann werden die auch dementsprechend durchgeroutet. Dann gehen die mal quer durch Europa und wieder zurück und wieder quer.
Was ist noch neu bei den iPhones, was wir letzte Woche noch nicht behandelt haben?
Na, dieses Background-NFC. Also es gibt jetzt schon so Zugangskarten für Studenten zum Beispiel, oder auch für die Londoner Oberen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das auch NFC ist, aber wo du mit deinem Telefon so sagen kannst, ich hab hier Zugang und gehst durch. Und wenn das Telefon dann aber leer war, dann ging das nicht mehr. Und jetzt gibt es wohl nur für bestimmte NFC-Karten, die das Telefon simuliert, die müssen noch so ein Feature haben, ich weiß nicht mehr, wie der hieß, funktionieren die Karten auch noch in so einem Rest-Spar-Modus irgendwie. Wenn das Telefon schon leer ist, dann kriegt das NFC immer noch so minimal Strom, dass die doch noch für eine Weile funktionieren. Aber es geht nur so lange auf dem Display auch noch, dass Ladesymbol erscheint. Wenn das dann auch so leer ist, dass das auch nicht mehr kommt, dann gehen auch diese NFC-Karten nicht mehr. So hab ich's mir gemerkt. Hält dann halt noch mal ein, zwei, drei Stunden länger, dass du nicht, wenn dein Telefon jetzt leer ist, und nicht das sofort auf der U-Bahn schlafen musst. Wenn du in der U-Bahn nicht mehr rein und rauskommst und nichts geht, sondern dann geht's wenigstens noch ein bisschen. Ich weiß ja gar nicht, wie lange dieses Ladesymbol da ist. Weil immer wenn ich das sehe, hab ich natürlich sofort Panik und schließ da sofort Strom an. Und ehrlich gesagt, hab ich das schon ewig nicht mehr gesehen, weil ich schließ da immer sofort Strom an.
Auf jeden Fall erhöht das die Nützlichkeit als Zugangs-Device nennenswert.
Ist aber auch jetzt nicht so eine Apple-Eigenerfindung, weil wie gesagt, die Karten müssen dafür auch irgendwie so ein Feature irgendwie können. Also die Karten, die dann simuliert werden, anscheinend, mit NFC oder wie. Keine Ahnung.
Ja, ansonsten, wie ist so das Xs? Ns?
Also ein bisschen CPU-schneller merkt man nicht, GPU ist ein bisschen schneller, merkt man nicht. Batterie soll besser halten, so wenig, dass man es auch nicht merkt. Display ist ja irgendwie auch wohl ein bisschen besser. Habe ich noch überhaupt gar keinen Unterschied festgestellt, habe mich aber auch noch nicht drum gekümmert. Was man aber merkt, ist, weil ich habe es mal mit dem Alten verglichen, die weite Linse hier.
Die untere.
Die untere, also ich nehme an, dass es die untere ist.
Wenn man das Telefon vor sich hält, ist es die untere Linse?
Ja, stimmt. Kann ich ja meinen Finger draufhalten? Nein, guck, es ist die obere. Weil das ist jetzt die weite Linse und ich bin mit dem Finger unten drauf und ich sehe immer noch was. Also die obere ist die weite Linse. Wenn ich hier umschalte auf dem Nah, dann ist es immer noch die obere. Das ist ja ein Ding.
Eine der Linsen.
Okay, ich bin verwirrt, ich ziehe alles zurück. Also man kann auch diese Zoom-Stufe hin und her wechseln zwischen einfacher und zweifacher, aber in beiden ist es die obere Linse, die er benutzt. Hier, ich halte die untere zu und ich kann hier hin und her schalten und er switcht hin und her, obwohl mein Finger auf der Linse... Ah, jetzt hat er gerade umgeschaltet. Ich meine, ich habe hier die Kamera auf den Rechner gehalten, der war anscheinend so nah, dass er der Meinung war, er braucht dann die andere Linse nicht. Als ich es hier in den Raum gehalten habe, dann hat er sehr wohl umgeschaltet. Jetzt schon auch wieder nicht. Es ist strange, da scheint das irgendwie von irgendwelchen Sachen abhängig zu machen.
Das hängt tatsächlich vom Abstand ab, ja.
Ja, und wenn man anfängt, die Kamera zu bewegen, dann, wupp, auf einmal schaltet er verzögert um. Ist egal. Was wollte ich erzählen? Jedenfalls habe ich beide Telefone nebeneinander gehalten, zu Hause in meiner nicht ganz so hellen Bude. Also, keine Ahnung, war jedenfalls gerade nicht so hell. Und die alte, das alte iPhone X hat schon angezeigt, dass es jetzt den Blitz benutzt, das neue noch nicht, weil ja die Pixel, also die Linse sozusagen ein bisschen größer ist und ein bisschen mehr Licht aufnimmt und dann ein bisschen lichtempfindlicher ist. Und das ist zum Fotos machen schon ganz gut. Ach so, ja, das ist dadurch, dass diese Linse ein bisschen größer ist, haben sie dieses ovale Ding auf der Rückseite, diesen Hump oder wie man ihn nennt, oder Bump. Keine Ahnung, das was so absteht. Der ist etwas größer nach unten. Dadurch passen die alten Hüllen nicht mehr so richtig drauf. Das ist so ein halber Millimeter, das ist wirklich nicht viel, aber die Hülle hängt dann so an dieser Kante fest. Das heißt, wer sich ein neues iPhone Xs holt, muss eventuell auch eine neue Hülle kaufen, weil die alte, wenn sie sehr perfekt sitzt, dann eben nicht mehr passt. Bei den Lederhüllen soll es übrigens nicht ganz so schlimm sein, die sollen noch drüber rutschen, weil die so ein bisschen mehr Spiel haben. Aber diese hier ist so eng gewesen, dass die nicht mehr gepasst hat. Also meine alte Hülle. Ja und sonst? Same, same, but different.
Du wolltest sozusagen vor allen Dingen Wertstabilität, also günstig verkaufen, damit du günstig verkaufst.
Nee, mir ist ja immer schon die Fotoqualität sehr wichtig, weil alles, was ich mit diesem Phone mache, ob das jetzt der bessere Bildschirm ist oder bessere Boxen, das ist mir nur für den Moment wichtig und dann ein Jahr später egal. Aber alle Fotos, die ich schieße, werde ich in wahrscheinlich zehn Jahren vielleicht mir immer noch angucken und da ist die Qualität mir schon doch sehr wichtig. Deswegen ist es mir eine gute Kamera, ist mir ein bisschen was wert. Und Licht stärker ist immer eine gute Sache. Weil auch bei normalem Licht ja eigentlich ist es ja dann auch schon weniger verrauscht und so weiter und so fort, also schon cool und dieses Portrait-Feature hier mit diesem Bokeh-Effekt habe ich glaube ich auch schon mal ausgetestet.
Ja, auf dem Friedhof.
Das war eigentlich auch ganz witzig, aber ja, ist schon auch so ein bisschen eine Spielerei natürlich.
Ja, beim alten X ist halt auch die Front-Facing-Kamera einfach nicht so geil, sodass dann dieser Porträt-Modus vergleichsweise sinnlos ist, finde ich. Ich habe es sozusagen aber auch noch nicht mit der guten Kamera getestet.
Ja, ich bin gespannt, wie die neue Kamera sich so bewährt, weil ich als, so was ich bisher an Reviews gelesen habe, ist wohl der große Unterschied halt a, das Verhalten im Dunkeln. Also durch diesen größeren Sensor holt das Ding wohl wirklich erstaunlich viel mehr Licht raus und schafft es, gute Sachen zu machen, was insbesondere sich auch bei Videos zeigen soll. Da es ja noch ein zweites Feature gibt, wenn du nämlich ein Video machst, nimmst du mit 30 Frames auf.
Also er schaltet jetzt dynamisch die Frame Rate um, so haben die irgendwas erzählt. Der nimmt eigentlich 60 Frames und wenn es zu dunkel ist, dann schaltet er auf 30 runter. So war es, dynamisch.
Nee, du nimmst mit 30 auf und er nimmt aber während der Aufnahme quasi schon mit 60, also er nimmt nicht mit 60 Frames auf, aber er filmt, also beobachtet mit 60 Frames und nimmt diesen Frame dazwischen, um quasi einen Diff zu haben zwischen den beiden Frames, um dadurch eben das Bild zu verbessern. Und wenn es besonders dunkel ist, schaltet er auf 24 Frames runter, um noch mehr Zeit zu haben für das Licht. Und das führt wohl zu erstaunlichen, besseren Ergebnissen. Ich habe aber jetzt noch nicht so viel AB.
Ist natürlich aber dann auch uncool für Leute, die die Videos wirklich irgendwie professionell nutzen wollen, wenn die dann andauernd zwischen 30 und 24 Frames hin und her springen. Weil du brauchst eine Frame Rate eigentlich. Aber wahrscheinlich kann man das irgendwo festnageln.
Das kann sein, dass man das festnageln kann. Das weiß ich jetzt nicht so ganz genau. Andererseits, wenn du wirklich so professionell und im Dunkeln ad hoc... Also ich glaube, die Hauptanwendung ist so dieses... Das Licht ist so wie es ist und du willst halt jetzt das bestmögliche Ergebnis haben. Wenn es dir jetzt um professionelles Bild geht, dann... Naja, wenn du wirklich so im so Dunkeln filmen musst, dann weiß ich nicht, ob dann das noch das Werkzeug der Wahl ist. Oder ob man da nicht mit anderem Equipment rangehen muss.
Eine Lampe zum Beispiel.
Einfach noch ein bisschen Licht draufstreuen.
Aber konnte man das jetzt eigentlich mit diesem Effekt, die Veränderung des Hinterkronens nur mit dem neuen iPhone machen? Oder auch mit dem Zehner jetzt?
Hatte ich dir nicht ein Foto rübergeschickt und bei dir ging es auch?
Nee, da hatte ich ja noch das SE in der Hand und ich habe das jetzt halt gerade versucht.
Ich glaube, dass das ging. Jetzt musst du nochmal...
Wovon redet ihr? Von dem nachträglichen Anpassen des Bucky?
Ich probiere das mal hier editieren und dann... Wo geht das überhaupt?
Ah, hier.
Genau, unscharf so.
Den habe ich nämlich nicht.
Jetzt schicke ich es dir mal rüber und dann kannst du das ja selber testen. Hier, mach mal auf.
Blauzahn wieder anmachen.
Ich sehe alle, nur dich nicht.
Ja, weil ich meinen Bluetooth nie anhabe.
Wieso hast du deinen Bluetooth nicht an?
Na, weil die Kabelmark...
Bist du ja wohl zu feinführend? Ja. Während Dennis und Letty hier noch heiße Fotos tauschen. Wir wollen die aber auch sehen.
Aber ich kann das nicht ändern, wenn ich auf edit gehe.
Nee, ich glaube, das ist...
Na, bei mir war es, als wenn da stand, dass das...
Ich glaube, das ist schon so ein 10s-Feature. Ob das wirklich jetzt nur weggelassen wurde oder ob das von der Performance des Steins abhängt und es eine gute Erklärung dafür gibt, kann ich dir nicht sicher sagen. Gibt es bestimmt irgendeine passende Verschwörungstheorie mit Apple will seine User erpressen, so wie das maximale Geld rausholen und so.
Ich glaube aber, bei dem Grober stand da irgendwas dazu. Da müsste man noch mal gucken.
Ich dachte, wir hätten auch darüber gequatscht und dass das ein Feature ist, was für alle zugänglich sein sollte. Also zugänglich für die X-Varianten, die 10 Varianten.
Gut, das Rätsel können wir jetzt nicht klären. Also denken wir noch nicht weiter drüber nach, oder?
Wenn wir gerade bei dieser iPhone-Geschichte sind, dann kann ich ja vielleicht so meine ersten Eindrücke vom Wechsel von dem iPhone SE zum XC, wie auch immer mal berichten.
Denn Letty ist ja quasi das Vehikel zu Dennis Upgrade.
Ich bin der Nutznießer.
Je nach Perspektive, ja.
Ich wollte mir ja nur die neuen iPhones einfach noch mal anschauen im Laden und Dennis hat mir die einfach in die Hand gedrückt. Also womit ich in der Tat keine guten Erfahrungen vielleicht noch nicht gemacht hab, ist mit der Face ID. Also ich hab das ziemlich häufig tagsüber, dass wenn ich versuche, das Telefon zu entsperren, dass ich mehrmals reinschauen muss. Und wirklich so gefühlt vor meinem Gesicht so Hand auszudecken.
Vielleicht schaust du einfach zu skeptisch.
Ja, vielleicht schaue ich. Oder deine Brille schirmt zu viel ab.
Aber ich bin mir da nicht sicher. Also ich habe halt eine relativ große Brille und Roddy sagte, er hätte null Probleme. Und er hat aber eine viel, viel kleinere Brille, die nicht so viel Gesichtsfläche verdeckt. Das würde mich mal interessieren, ob das halt auch andere Personen haben. Und so morgens im Bett, ey, es ist ja... Nee, wer hat sich denn das bitte überlegt? So morgens im Bett willst du dein Telefon einfach nur greifen und entsperren und nicht erst mal das Licht anmachen und ich kriege das ohne Licht nicht entsperrt. Mit Brille oder ohne Brille? Ich bekomme das Telefon nicht entsperrt. Man muss vielleicht auch wirklich dazu sagen, ja, ich habe schwarze Bettwäsche und ja, ich habe schwarze Haare. Und da würde mich echt mal interessieren, ob das ein Problem ist.
Das soll ja jetzt nur nicht... Mach mal Licht aus, Tim.
Ich weiß nicht, woran das liegt. Vielleicht halte ich es einfach. Nur falsch, das wird es sein. Vielleicht halte ich das ja hier so, die andere Kamera.
Oder du bist zu sorgfältig, weil du meintest ja vorhin schon im Pre-Show-Talk, dass du mit Brille, ohne Brille, mit Ohrstöpsel, ohne Ohrstöpsel, die versucht hast zu trainieren. Vielleicht bist du schon zu vorsichtig. Vielleicht solltest du einfach du selbst sein.
Nein, den ersten Tag habe ich das iPhone nur mit meinem... Mit dem Gesicht, was man hat, nachdem man aufgestanden ist. Mit Brille, mit den plaxenden Ohren. Also ich weiß nicht, also angezogen. Und das hat eigentlich auch nicht besser funktioniert. Deswegen dachte ich ja so, okay, ich mache das einfach noch ein zweites.
Hast du denn nachdem du das eingerichtet hast, ein paar mal den Fall gehabt, dass es dich nicht erkennt und du hast dann danach sofort den Passcode eingegeben?
Nee, ich habe das dann so lange versucht, bis ich nicht mehr anders konnte.
Das ist aber das, was du tun solltest.
Ja, warum habe ich denn dann Face ID?
Na der Punkt ist, wenn es dich nicht erkennt und nach einem Passcode fragt und du gibst dann sofort deinen Passcode ein, dann wird das Bild, was du genommen hast, als A du bist es doch und dann wird da der Diff und dann wird es Refined. Das heißt, du hast quasi das Refinement umgangen und vielleicht ist sozusagen ihm auch die ganze Zeit gesagt, ich bin es eigentlich gar nicht. Also durch diese Trainingsphase musste man die ersten Tage etwas durch und ich dachte auch, so soll das jetzt immer so bleiben und dann war das irgendwann weg. Irgendwann kennt dich das Ding einfach.
Ja, dann werde ich da einfach mal konsequenter jetzt das Ding eingeben.
Einfach Nummern eintippen und 3, 4, 5, 6 mal und dann verschwindet es irgendwie. Also das war zumindest jetzt meine Erfahrung. Ich kann nicht, ich kann, ich habe auch, also ich würde mir auch wünschen, dass es noch etwas schneller geht und das ist ja beim S ist das jetzt wohl auch so. Schneller geht immer, aber es ist ja trotzdem schnell, aber ich habe eigentlich in der Regel kein Problem. Manchmal finde ich es ein bisschen inconvenient, was weiß ich, wenn das Telefon in der Mittelkonsole vom Auto hängt und du willst mal was machen, dann lockt sich das und dann musst du da irgendwie hingucken und im Auto ist das ja mal alles blöd, irgendwo anders hingucken will man nicht. Da finde ich es noch ein bisschen inconvenient, aber an sich so im normalen Benutzen, wenn man diesen Spaß mit Retraining ein paar Mal gemacht hat, dann sollte das eigentlich kein Problem sein.
Hier wird auch gerade im Chat geschrieben, dass es eben so Mindestabstand ist, dass man da auch mal drauf achten soll. Das ist mir auch aufgefallen, dass wenn ich es dann weiter wegnehme, vielleicht auch noch mal mehr der Ehe erkennt.
Aber wie gesagt, eigentlich, wie Tim schon sagt, ist der Zustand am Ende so, dass man sich da eigentlich keine Gedanken drüber machen kann. Und ich bin eher überrascht, in welchen Winkeln und unmöglichen Situationen das noch funktioniert und wie selten ich dann so sage, ja okay, jetzt gerade hier ist so ein bisschen schwierig, okay, ich gebe mal den Quot ein. Also gerade so dieses hier, es liegt nur so auf dem Tisch und ich habe jetzt keinen Bock, so rüber zu luken, dann ja okay, fine, ich gebe mal kurz den Passquot ein. Aber eigentlich sollte das relativ beschwerdefrei laufen.
Also ich habe halt auch das alternative Erscheinungsbild konfiguriert, das ist dann quasi Letty-Minus-Brille und ich werde das jetzt einfach mal weiterversuchen und den halt anlernen, wenn ihr sagt, öfter mal den Passquot eingeben.
Genau.
Oder einfach mal ohne Aufmerksamkeitsprüfung, ohne dieses Hingucken. Weil du wirst jetzt nicht so oft den Fall haben, dass dir irgendjemand das Telefon in deine Nähe hält und... Also, es ist dieses Kinderproblem, Kinder klauen die ganze Zeit das Telefon und halten einem das dann so kurz vor das Gesicht. Und das kann ich halt noch unterbinden, wenn ich nicht hingucke. Aber wenn ich halt diese Aufmerksamkeitsprüfung ausschalte, dann könnte ich es halt noch schneller machen und schneller irgendwo in irgendeiner Ecke verschwunden und spielen wieder das Game of the Day, als man reagieren kann.
Ja, nee, das sollte nicht mein Problem sein. Ich werde es ausprobieren. Aber vom Format her kannst du auch noch nichts zu sagen, oder?
Das kann man relativ schnell sagen. Du musst einfach nur mal, wenn du nach Hause kommst, und so ist ja nicht weit, dein Altes in die Hand nehmen und man will eigentlich merken, nee, da kann ich nicht mehr zurück.
Also ich meine, ich finde jetzt halt auch, ich habe jetzt das erste Mal wieder das Gefühl, dass ich besser tippe. Also das hatte ich bei dem SE total häufig, dass ich mich vertippt hatte, und ich hatte halt einfach keinen Bock mehr, Texte auf dem Telefon zu tippen. Ich habe keine E-Mails mehr geschrieben.
Du schreibst E-Mails auf dem Telefon?
Jetzt wieder. Also mit dem neuen Telefon habe ich da sogar Bock drauf, weil, was weiß ich.
Kannst du auch diktieren?
Ich rede nicht mit meinem Telefon. Ich rede mit niemandem, wenn ich nicht musste.
Willkommen in der Freak Show.
Nein, ich finde das nervig, wenn ich zu Hause bin und Ruhe ist und ich Musik hören kann.
Kannst du denn auch?
Ich möchte nicht mit meinem Telefon reden.
Wenn du alleine bist, dann geht das ja auch.
Irgendwann wird Siri einem sagen, dass es einsam ist und sich vernachlässigt fühlt.
Ja, das denkt das Telefon wahrscheinlich wirklich gerade, weil es nicht mehr zum Sport darf.
Ich bin's, dein iPhone SE.
Ich hab's oben ins Bett gelegt, damit es nicht so einsam ist.
Wieso, wer ist denn jetzt in deinem Bett?
Das ist iPhone.
Aber es ist immer noch einsam.
iPhone im Bett.
Na ja, iPhone im Bett, noch so ein benutztes T-Shirt daneben, da kann man dann nicht einsam sein.
Anstatt eines Teddybärens liegt da jetzt das iPhone SE.
Das ist ein bisschen hart.
Zum Einschlafen.
Zum Kuscheln.
Das ist ein bisschen hart zum Kuscheln.
So ist das im Einstieg.
Anstelle von so einem Teddybär hast du jetzt für uns hier die Kekse aufgemacht, die haben wir so nett von dir. Kannst du knicken.
Mit Plüschhülle.
Nee, das ist schon irgendwie ein cooleres Telefon, ist schon irgendwie cooler, aber ich find's in der Tat ein Stück zu lang für meine kleinen Finger. Also so ist es. Hätte ein Stück kürzer für mich sein können, aber ich meine, ich hoffe, ich gewöhn mich da dran. Ich hab natürlich permanent Angst, dieses Ding runterzuschmeißen.
Benutz du den, wie heißt der noch gleich eigentlich, dieser Modus? Na, wenn man unten so runter schubst, ist das noch gleich.
Den gibt's ja nicht mehr.
Wie gibt's den nicht mehr?
Gibt's den noch?
Was soll denn hier passieren, da kommt die Suche.
Nein, wenn du ganz, wie noch? Das war nie weg.
Du kannst hier unten, mit dem kleinen Schnupsi kannst du, ja, aber das, das, also man muss noch so ganz klein machen, wenn man die Größe macht, kommt ja gleich, ja, du machst so einen kleinen, auf diesem Balken, habe ich das ausgeschaltet oder? Kleiner Schnupsi nach unten und dann, dann kommt halt der Bildschirm so zur Hälfte runter und dann kann man halt auch alles noch, also das geht auch, in Apps geht das ja, also außerhalb von, geht immer. Also im Springboard geht's nicht, so meine ich. Im Springboard geht's nicht?
Wahrscheinlich habe ich das ausgeschaltet, weil das im SE keine sinnvolle Anordnung hat.
Kann man gar nicht ausschalten. Nee, nach unten.
Der Chat behauptet, es müsste extra eingeschaltet werden.
Offenbar. Aber ich weiß gar nicht, wo denn.
Ja, das geht mir auch manchmal so. Wo habe ich das jetzt noch mal eingeschaltet?
Einstellungen Allgemeinen Bedienungshilfen natürlich, klar. Wo sonst? Allgemeinen, tralala.
Der Chat hat es wieder gerichtet.
Bedienungshilfen und dann heißt es wie?
Allgemein Accessibility, ja.
Einhandmodus, guck an.
Weiter unten oder wo?
Ja, so in der Mitte von Bedienungshilfen.
Nee, mir geht es auch nicht wirklich um die, dass es zu lang ist, ja, während ich das Telefon bediene, sondern wenn ich es in der Hand halte, weil ich hab immer so, also es ist halt nur so ein Stück physisch zu lang. Da reden wir der nächste Sendung drüber.
Da wirst du dich gar nicht mehr dran erinnern, dass du das gesagt hast. Bist du mir relativ sicher.
Ja und was ich auf jeden Fall merke, also ich hab halt, bin sehr empfindlich was meine Augen angehen und wenn es sich unterschiede, also wenn ich neue Bildschirme habe, das merke ich sofort und ich muss mich da erst dran gewöhnen. Und die ersten zwei Tage waren mit dem neuen Bildschirm auf jeden Fall eine ganz schöne Umgewöhnung und ich hatte Augenschmerzen.
Aber in einer Hinsicht dürfte dieser Bildschirm ja wirklich extrem entgegenkommen.
Weil er schwarz war? Ja aber ich hab selten irgendeinen, ich hab jetzt…
Es gibt so viel Dark Mode, also Twitter Dark Mode, Rima Dark Mode, Dark Mode, hier Dark Mode da.
Ja und nein, ich meine das Schwarz auf so einem OLED ist halt richtig schwarz.
Aber wenn ich dieses…
So schwarz war dein Telefon noch nie.
Ich finde den Einhand-Modus nicht im Englischen.
Aber ich will hier nicht alles so komplett schwarz haben, weil ich habe so ein schönes Hintergrundbild.
Reachability heißt es.
Ich will gerne nicht erdrossen werden.
Das war das Wort, was ich gesucht habe.
Ich glaube, ich hab in… hab ich überhaupt eine App, die ich…
Also Letty ist nicht zufrieden bisher.
Nein, nein, doch, doch, das würde ich nicht sagen, aber wenn das schwarze Feature das einzige Feature ist, also ein Schwarz soll es mir nicht mangeln. Nein, weiß ich nicht. Ich finde das ganz cool auf jeden Fall, aber ebenso diese Umgewöhnung vom Bildschirm fand ich wieder spannend. Also weil da weiß ich, dass ich sehr, sehr empfindlich bin und so Kopfschmerzen…
Mach erst mal ein paar Fotos mit dem Teil, da wirst du schon merken…
Hab ich schon.
dass du dein SE nicht mehr vermisst.
Ne, deswegen habe ich es ja auch, also das hat mir ja Dennis auch angeboten, das überhaupt auszuprobieren, das Telefon, weil ich ja eigentlich ein bisschen geliebäugelt habe mit dem SX…
Aber auch nur aus einem Grund, weil es gibt nämlich ein Gold.
Das Gold ist schöner. Ja, ich habe mich an diese Farbe jetzt halt gewöhnt und das ist gerade noch so ein bisschen… Das ist noch nicht das Lettifon.
Aber kannst du es nicht mit goldem Nagellack übermalen?
Gestern hatte ich noch ein lustiges Erlebnis und zwar ein Freund von mir hat sich beschwert, dass wenn er ja auf dem Phone Mails liest und die noch so… Dass so viele Updates sind, dass wenn er schon anfängt zu sortieren und so Sachen in andere Orner verschiebt, aber gleichzeitig noch frische reinkommen, dass es ab und zu passiert, dass er die falsche wegschiebt oder die falsche löscht, weil ihm das sozusagen unter am Arsch, dass die Anzeige sich ändert und das schon wieder die nächste Mail ist und er meint, das ist doch voll scheiße und dann weiß man nicht, wo die hin ist und welche das war und man kann da nichts rückgängig machen und nicht so, doch kannst du ganz einfach fixen, du musst nur dein Telefon schütteln. Und er hat so geguckt, als wenn ich ihn voll verarschte. Ich hab gesagt, ja doch, hier schüttel mal und ich hab das noch nie benutzt selber eigentlich.
Brando.
Genau, aber gar keine Ahnung. Und er hat geschüttelt, guckt auf den Bildschirm und steht da ja hier löschen, irgendwie rückgängig machen oder cancel, weißt schon und er so, boah, das ist ja geil. Gleich hat er seiner Freundin gerannt und hat, hier guck mal da, das Problem ist gelöst. Voll jemand mit Telefonschütteln glücklich gemacht, fand ich voll gut, weil ich mag das Feature gar nicht. Weil manch mal von alleine kommt und dann steht da irgendwie so da, hier, das und das und dann so, oh, chatterhands.
Ja, aber da sind wir aber bei einem guten Punkt. Wie würdest du Andu anders machen, als so, wie sie es gemacht haben?
Ja, gute Frage.
Ein X-Ochter.
Andu, die Geschichte von Andu ist auch eine Geschichte der Missverständnisse. Also, ich find ja Andu eine der größten.
Da gab's doch letztens erst die Story dazu.
Herr Wunsch, jetzt hast du schon wieder dein Mikrofon so gebogen, dass es irgendwo dein Auge zeigt.
Okay, kannst du mal bitte, wir haben ja unseren Audiomann und der Audiomann, der ja auch Podcasts macht, wie man Podcasts aufnimmt.
Du musst, guck mal, wenn du es hochmachst, dann musst du das hier links, am... Direkt an der Achse, am Drehgelenk, am Schwenkgelenk, musst du das so nach oben machen. Und dann kehrt es wieder zurück. Aber wenn du die ganze Zeit am Schwanenhals selber drehst, dann... Passt dem Schwan nicht an den Hals.
Und dann, drei Sekunden später, dann krieg ich von Letty wieder haue, weil ich wieder in mein Mikro weide.
Na, es ist halt so ein Geräusch, wo ich halt einschlafe, potenziell.
Von Vedern.
Okay, Andu.
Die letzten zehn Minuten.
Ich halte Andu an sich für eine unfassbare Errungenschaft. Ich finde es überhaupt auch ganz toll, dass Apple sich generell mit Andu ja viel Mühe gibt. Und alle Programme, die Andu richtig machen, sind sowieso zu belobigen.
Was ist denn das richtige Andu deiner Meinung nach?
Naja, so vollständig und so persistent wie möglich.
Und auch Multipath-Andu. Also es gibt ja quasi Verästelungen teilweise auch noch. Das wäre für mich ja die Königsdisziplin.
Wenn man es richtig macht, ist es dann ja eigentlich gar nicht mehr so schwierig. Es ist nur eine Frage des User Interfaces. Also musst du dann halt diesen Pfad, diesen Baum, der sich daraus ergibt, den müsstest du dann ja quasi abbilden. Aber wie lange hat das gedauert, bis man überhaupt ordentliches Andu hatte, was man so über einen Schritt hinausging? Also lange, lange Zeit war das so Photoshop, die frühen Tage. Da kannst du dann mal grad so den letzten Schritt rückgängig machen und das war's. Der war aber auch nur im Speicher und wenn du...
Ich überleg grad, weil ich benutze ja, ich hatte ja gerade erst vor kurzem mal wieder so die ganzen Bildbearbeitungstools durch und hab dann auch überlegt, ja, ich hab mit Photoshop 2.5 angefangen und tatsächlich hab ich genau auch schon da drüber nachgedacht, wann so bestimmte Interface-Schritte kamen. Und Andu, ja wann war das, bei welcher Version?
Also Multiple Andu weiß ich nicht.
Aber es kam... Ja klar, das Multiple Andu kam irgendwann später.
Und es ist ja auch nicht so einfach, weil du musst ja dann auch den entsprechenden Speicherer und die Daten alle vorrätig halten. Und bei diesen massiven Operationen, gut es gibt andere Programme, da ist nicht ganz so viel Daten verbunden, aber du kannst eigentlich auch in so was wie einem Texteditor relativ schnell sehr viel Speicher auffressen und irgendwo muss auch ein Ende sein. Oder man macht es halt auch gleich persistent. Also wird ein Andu auch gleich mit abgespeichert, wenn du dein Dokument abspeichert, was dann wieder so ein Sicherheitsproblem ist. So Word-Dokumente, wo dann die letzten zehn Beschimpfungen noch irgendwo in der Datei nachzulesen sind und so. Ja, also wo speicherst du das hin? So, das ist das eine. So, am Computer war natürlich das mit dem User-Interface jetzt nicht das Problem, weil du machst irgendwie Apfel-Z, da hast du dann Andu. Aber auf dem Telefon, ein generelles Andu, was nicht ein eigenes User-Interface-Element hat, ist halt echt die Frage, was kannst du da als Input überhaupt noch nehmen?
Wie auf Buttons.
Kurze Zwischenfrage, wie oft kann man denn eigentlich zurückschütteln? Kann man dann? Also ich habe bisher immer nur einmal zurückgeschüttelt.
Das hängt, glaube ich, im Wesentlichen von deinem Programm ab. Das Schütteln löst halt ein Anduevent aus und dann hängt es an deinem Programm ab. Hast du denn schon mal mehrfach geschüttelt? Mehrfach geschüttelt bin ich nicht.
Okay, ich probiere es jetzt mal in der Notepad-App aus.
Genau, mach das doch mal. Aber gibt es irgendwelche anderen Ideen, wie man auf einem Mobiltelefon Andu machen sollte? Weil dadurch ist es ja universell verfügbar.
Ich meine, also bei dem iPhone X bin ich ja, X, wie jetzt auch immer, bin ich ja eh schon so ein bisschen begeistert von dem Space, der der Tastatur eingeräumt wird. Also es ist ja eine Menge Space, die einfach jetzt zur Verfügung steht. Und du hast unten gerade die Weltkugel für die verschiedenen Tastaturen und die Diktierfunktion. In der Mitte ist noch eine Menge Platz. Da hast du ja, wie du mir vorhin gezeigt hast, diesen Cursor aktivieren drin.
Das kannst du überall machen. Du kannst irgendwo auf die Tastatur drücken und dann hast du Cursor.
Aber ich meine, da unten wäre ja noch so ein bisschen Space. Also ich finde halt diese Ando, gut, das ist halt im Text editieren, fände ich es halt bescheuert, ständig zu schütteln, um mir was Ando zu machen.
Genau, das habe ich gerade gemacht in der Notpad-App. Und es ist so, wenn man was bei der Notpad-App eingibt und am Ende auf dann klickt, dann ist dieser ganze Editiervergang ein Ando-Step. Wenn man sozusagen mehrere Male was eintippt und jedes Mal dazwischen dieses dann mit Editing und so macht, dann kann man tatsächlich alle diese Schritte einzeln andunen. Und dann beim Mehrfachschütteln gibt es dann die Option Redo oder Ando. Also du kannst dann sozusagen auch noch Redo machen. Also Freak Show berichtet live aus der Notpad-App.
Als ich das erste Mal in meinem Leben den Begriff Undo Framework gelesen habe, ist mir wirklich was abgegangen. Das fand ich einfach richtig geil. Also die Idee allein für Ando ein eigenes Framework zu bauen, finde ich einfach mal...
Und eigentlich ist das auch ziemlich simpel. Da steht da, dass man ja, man muss das Ding ja füttern mit den Schritten. Man muss immer nur bei jeder Aktion, der einem Ando Framework geben, was man machen müsste, um genau diese Aktion wieder rückgängig zu machen. Und mehr ist das ja eigentlich gar nicht. Und so spult er die dann, wenn du mehrmals, also auch auf dem Mac, wenn du mehrmals Apple Z hintereinander drückst, spult er die einzelnen Dinge einfach nacheinander ab und dann werden die alle wieder zurückgenommen.
Was halt interessant ist, dieses ganze Historien, Aufzeichnungs, Ando, redo und so weiter zu machen, ist halt auch in der Visualisierung lange irgendwie ein großes Thema gewesen, wie man das ordentlich macht, wenn du halt so Nutzern, dann so viele Interaktionen einfach ermögligst und grad halt so, wenn du dann also bei Visualisierung hast, halt so im Visual Analytics Bereich irgendwie auch über, was ich schon mal erzählt hatte, mit mehreren Leuten einen Arbeitsplatz teilen und so ne Sachen, wo das irgendwie immer noch so ein großes Gebiet ist, wo Leute dran forschen. Also fand ich halt spannend, weil ich hab das bis dato immer so als, ja, halt gegeben wahrgenommen. Das ist es aber eben nicht so.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das auf dem Rechner vor dem Mac, also auf groß und ganz noch auf meinem Amiga, ob es da schon so in den Texteditoren so mehrstufiges Ando gegeben hat, hab ich gar keine Ahnung mehr.
Das war so eine Entwicklung über die Jahre. Also überhaupt Ando war schon mal eine Errungenschaft, generell auf dem Mac und dann kam später Multiple Ando und dann kam irgendwann auch mal so Persistentes Ando. Aber das haben auch die wenigsten Programme heutzutage, was mir sehr schade ist.
Mir ist es letztens aufgefallen, wenn wir so gerade bei Ando uns so Shortcut-Sachen sind. Ich würd mir auch so einen Keks freuen, wenn die Leute bei Apple, danke Ruckel für den Keks, wenn die Leute bei Apple in dieser Notes App und dass es so einen Standard dafür geben würde, wie Steuerung Z, Steuerung V und C.
Steuerung?
Scheiße, stimmt.
In der Jugend alten Freak Show.
Für so Zeilen duplizieren und Zeilen hoch und runter schieben. Also ich bin das so aus dem Editor gewöhnt, irgendwie eine Zeile hoch und runter zu schieben. Und da ich zum Beispiel in der Notes App meine gesamten To Do's verwalte und irgendwelchen anderen Geraffel, wenn die das dann einfach mal einfügen könnten, dass man so mit Shift oder irgendwas Cursor dann schön die Zeilen hoch und runter schieben könnte, wenn das so ein Standard wäre.
Jetzt sollte es ja doch mal die...
Das ist der Standard und da heißt es Emax.
Oder Wim. Aber bei Emax noch viel mehr, ja.
Aber ich meine, da geht es ja wirklich nur um diese Notes App. Und ich finde es halt schon irgendwie ganz nice, das so ein bisschen so ein Interface zu haben für verschiedene Gruppen und sowas.
Das wäre dein Notes Pro oder sowas.
Das wäre es mir wert. Also das fände ich halt...
Vielleicht ja in Mojave, wobei... Da habe ich jetzt auch noch nichts von gelesen. Das hat es ja auch noch mal aufgemacht. Da hat ja Dennis auch noch was zu berichten. Weil ich habe mir das noch nicht installiert. Unter anderem wegen der üblichen Audio-Gewitter, die potenziell dann als Spätfolge kommen. Und ich habe auch schon ein paar Newsletter von irgendwelchen Audio-Plugin-Herstellern bekommen, die meinten, ja, warte mal noch ein paar Tage. Wir checken mal gerade, ob da alles funktioniert. Deswegen, die Audionerds warten immer mit so einem MacOS-Upgrade ein bisschen. Aber ich habe mal die Zeit genutzt und geguckt, was so im Internet steht. Und ich habe gesehen bei AskTechnica, zwar nicht von Herrn Siracusa, aber da gibt es auch wieder eine schöne Übersicht, was sich alles so geändert hat, im Detail und im Großen.
Na, da habe ich jetzt Cunningham.
Den Link paste ich natürlich sofort. Ja, da sind auf jeden Fall so ein, zwei interessante Dinge drin. Ich finde ja, das hatten wir letztes Mal auch schon gesagt, dass sie jetzt OpenGL und OpenCL deprecaten und auch gar nichts mehr weiter dran machen, finde ich ja persönlich ein bisschen schade. Ich verstehe zwar, dass sie das pushen wollen und so weiter, aber wo soll ich dann meinen Minecraft spielen?
Na, auf Metal.
Ja, fraglich, ob sie diese Java-App mittels Metal-AP nochmal bestücken oder, weiß nicht, ob das überhaupt geht.
Weil sie jetzt direkt in Java auf OpenGL aufsetzen oder wie?
Ich weiß es nicht hundertprozentig, wie das funktioniert, aber wenn ich bei mir im Debug-Screen gucke, dann steht da auf jeden Fall OpenGL-Driver. Keine Ahnung, mal gucken. Trotz alledem finde ich es halt ein bisschen schade, weil es gibt halt schon zum Beispiel Open Source-Apps wie zum Beispiel auch dieses OpenCPN, diese Navigationssoftware. Wenn du die nicht OpenGL beschleunigst, dann ist die schnarchend langsam.
Also läuft es nicht mehr oder ist es nur deprecated?
Na, es läuft noch, aber sie updaten es halt sowieso schon seit Jahren nicht mehr, oder nicht seit Jahren, aber seit einiger Zeit. Und sie werden es jetzt auch definitiv nicht mehr updaten, während die restliche Betriebssystemwelt das halt noch fleißig tut. Und irgendwann werden sie es dann halt ganz ausmachen. Solange sie es jetzt noch mitschleifen, ist es okay. Und es steht ja auch nirgendswo, wann sie es dann wirklich komplett rausschmeißen. Ich finde es einfach ein bisschen doof.
Ich glaube, es muss noch über lange, lange Zeit drin sein, aber so schnell können sie das nicht rausschmeißen. Da sind so viele Sachen, die da drauf basieren. Also ich denke immer, sie wollen das in Richtung Metal drücken, aber sie müssen das schon noch ein paar Jahre mitschieben. Und das machen sie eigentlich auch bei den meisten Sachen. Wenn sie es dann wirklich abschaffen, ist ja dann, wenn sie irgendwas switchen, wie z.B. von 32 Bit nach 64 Bit, dann werden die halt nicht angepasst und so. Aber ich sehe da in der Zukunft erstmal nicht, wo dann das OpenGL irgendwie bei drauf gehen könnte. Aber aus Security-Gründen vielleicht, weil man wieder über die Grafik, keine Ahnung, sowas könnte vielleicht...
Ja, oder sie machen es halt wie mit dem X-Server, als sie den rausgeschmissen haben, dann gab es ihn da bei Mac OS Forge halt separat zum Runterladen.
Und es gibt ja auch schon irgendwie, gab es ein OpenGL nach Metal, ja wie soll man das nennen, Simulator, Emulator, so ein Anpass... Ja, irgendwie gab es da was, dass die Leute schneller dann da das anpassen können.
Naja, das ist aber auch nur eine kleine Randnotiz für die allermeisten User wahrscheinlich.
Was ist denn hier noch so aufgefallen? Ich klicke mir gerade mal durch den Artikel, ich hatte den noch nicht gesehen.
Ja, dieses Inhaltsverzeichnis ist eigentlich ganz gut da als Überblick, was sich so generell getan hat. Dieses Marzipan, das ist mir irgendwie total entgangen, dass sie da so ein iOS-UI-Kit quasi jetzt in Mojave mit reinshippen, damit man irgendwie besser Cross-Platform-Apps von...
Wie konnte dir das entgehen? Das war doch ein Riesenteil auf der WWDC.
Ich glaube, ich habe die WWDC einfach nicht geguckt. Ja, also das ist mir komplett entgangen bisher tatsächlich.
Dann bleiben wir noch mal kurz hier bei diesem Inhaltsverzeichnis. Da sind ja erstmal noch ein paar Tipps für Mac Pro. Da können wir vielleicht gleich noch mal drauf kommen. APFS ist jetzt sozusagen auf Fusion Drives auch erweitert. Beziehungsweise gibt es auch generell noch weitere Neuigkeiten?
Ja, da ist tatsächlich relativ viel im Dunkeln. Also Apple gibt wohl nicht so richtig Preis, was sie so noch getwiegt haben. Außer so die generellen Verbesserungen und Fehlerbehebungen. Genau, und eigentlich das wesentliche Feature ist, wie gesagt, jetzt dieser Fusion Drive und normaler Hard Drive Support.
Also dieser Fusion Support heißt ja auch, dass sie eigenständig Daten oder vollständige Files von dem einen auf den anderen Storage schieben. Also nicht nur so Block-Auflösungen haben, sondern im Prinzip so hier. Die Datei wurde lange nicht angefasst, die schieben wir jetzt mal auf die Festplatte und alles, was auf der Festplatte jüngst angefasst wurde, wird dann im Hintergrund halt übertragen, damit es dann eben auf der SSD im Zugriff ist. Das dauert eigentlich ganz gut und das ging halt bisher mit APFS nicht. Also es ist jetzt keine neue Funktionalität an sich, nur neu halt mit APFS. Sprich, sie werden jetzt diese Fusion Drives wahrscheinlich auch optimieren, also automatisch zu APFS überführen. Ja, dieser Dark Mode, ich weiß nicht, Dennis, du arbeitest ja schon damit.
Ich habe das seit gestern und ich habe das auf meinem Laptop nur mal schnell installiert, aber eigentlich habe ich das hauptsächlich viel auf meinem Mac Pro gemacht und getan und so weiter, was ich dann auch gleich noch erzähle. Oder jetzt, wenn er wollt.
Ja, dann machst du mal vielleicht einen Schluss als Grand Final.
Ja, glaube ich auch.
Ja, also ich meine, wie gesagt, wenn man die WC gesehen hat, hat man vielleicht das alles schon mitbekommen, aber hier zum Beispiel das jetzt hier, also die 32-Bit-Apps-Finalsterben zum Beispiel. Wusste ich jetzt auch nicht, dass das bei uns kommt.
Noch nicht, sondern jetzt wird's angezeigt, ne?
Nee, jetzt gehen sie, glaube ich, nicht mehr. Nee, angezeigt wurde schon mit High Sierra, da hieß es immer so, ja...
Also da unten steht, the end of the line for 32-Bit-Mac-Apps und jetzt noch mal hier kurz lesen. Ah, nee, das ist die letzte Version. Fertig lesen. Ja, also ich mein, im Wesentlichen sind ja auch die Features relativ übersichtlich. Also sie haben so ein paar Sachen halt rausgeschmissen oder bereiten den Rausschmiss vor, wie auch zum Beispiel die weitere Beschneidung des MacOS-Servers.
Ja, und Back to My Mac fällt jetzt auch komplett weg. Wo ich sagen muss, das hat auch in letzter Zeit so scheiße funktioniert, dass es eh schon nicht mehr zu benutzen war. Also ich weiß nicht, dass das Feature halt wie von Release zu Release immer weniger funktioniert.
Ansonsten ist es ja auch ein relativ unspektakuläres Release.
Naja, unten drunter passiert vielleicht auch nichts. Also wie da zum Beispiel auch steht, dieses Subpixel Anti-A-Lasing, das fällt jetzt auch weg. Das ist wahrscheinlich auch bei Retina-Displays, die so hochauflösend sind, da brauchst du das wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr und kostet nur extra CPU oder GPU-Zeit oder Batterie-Zeit am Ende.
Oder macht es halt auch schlimmer teilweise.
Oder macht es schlimmer, weil das halt ja auch Farbe in den schwarzen Text bringt, weil es ja High-Pixel sind und das gibt es jetzt nicht mehr. Wie gesagt, bei so hohen Auflösungen, jetzt braucht man das ja auch nicht mehr so wirklich. Also ich finde, der Runder...
War das im Wesentlichen, das war ja keine... Also das Pixel-Antialiasing war ja nicht nur wegen mangelnder hoher Auflösung, sondern das liegt doch auch spezifische Anzeige von LCDs aus. War das nicht so?
Hab ich jetzt nicht verstanden, was du meinst. Das war, um früher auf Displays mit nicht so hoher DPI-Zahl trotzdem die Kanten noch so ein bisschen rauszukriegen, indem man halt die ein Drittel Pixel benutzt hat, also nicht alle drei Farben ein oder ausschaltete, sondern nur rot oder nur grün, je nachdem, auf welcher Seite das war.
Ich verwechsel das, glaube ich, gerade mit irgendwas anderes. Es gab irgendwann mal auch so eine Anpassung auf die Problematik, wie das dann auf LCDs aussah, aber das kriege ich jetzt auch nicht mehr zusammen. Egal, erzähl mal weiter.
Ich auch nicht. Na jedenfalls, weil jetzt ja eigentlich so ziemlich alle supporteten Geräte und auch die meisten Monitore, was die Leute jetzt so haben, ist alles sehr hochauflösend. Also vor allem Retina, dass die das jetzt einfach wegfallen lassen und du das trotzdem nicht sehen kannst. Und wie Huckel schon meinte, teilweise sogar besser aussieht, weil diese Subpixel ja teilweise links rot und rechts grün irgendwie war, oder blau, nee, blau war in der Mitte. Blau haben sie sozusagen nie benutzt, weiß ich gar nicht. Nee, grün haben sie nie benutzt. Also mal eine Seite war rot so ein bisschen, andere Seite blau. Und das fällt jetzt weg. Also ich denke mal, dadurch spart man sich auch, ist das Rendern vielleicht ein bisschen flotter, weil es muss ja auch alles irgendwie angezeigt und durchgecheckt werden, ne? Dann, ich glaube, bei Mojave war das auch, es gab doch schon mit dem HiSera kam noch der Support für externe GPUs. Und man musste, wenn man so ein Ding ransteckt, aber sich immer noch ausloggen und dann, also mit seinem User, und dann wieder einloggen, damit man dann den zweiten Bildschirm irgendwie hatte. Und ich glaube, jetzt seit Mojave schließt man das an und das macht plopp und du hast einen weiteren Bildschirm. Also man muss nicht mehr aus- und einloggen, sondern das geht jetzt einfach so. Genau, also das Feature wurde nochmal more user-friendly gemacht. Ich denke mal, da geht es auch so ein bisschen hin in die Richtung mit, alles wird...
Also im Prinzip so wie man schaltet den zweiten Bildschirm an und geht halt einfach mit dazu, wie man es eben so kennt. Und jetzt geht es halt auch mit einer neuen Grafikkarte.
Genau, über hier Thunder-Dingens, Bold. Ich warte ja immer noch auf den... Also Apple baut ja keine Displays mehr, weiß ja auch nicht warum, aber auf das Display, wo die fette Grafikkarte halt schon drin ist im Display. Und auch Ethernet und alles, was man so haben will. Also mehr oder weniger der Desktop ist eigentlich, denn mein Display ist mein Desktop. Und dann komme ich nach Hause und stelle meinen Laptop hin, schließe das Kabel an und bäm, mein Display macht dann sozusagen alles und ist dann sogar grafikmäßig auch noch voll schnell. Wahrscheinlich noch mal 5 Jahre dazu und dann schaltest du sogar CPUs noch mit dazu, wer weiß.
Da bin ich mir noch nicht so richtig so sicher, ob das wirklich so eine zukunftstaugliche Entwicklung ist. Dass die Grafikkarte noch im Bildschirm mit drin ist.
Wieso nicht?
Na, weil die sich ja dann auch nicht aktualisiert. Wird ja nie schneller.
Wäre hier drin ja auch nicht im Laptop.
Ja, wir schließen einen anderen Computer an und dann ist der Bildschirm halt schneller, weil die Pixel werden halt aus dem Computer rausgedroschen.
Also meinst du, dass das eigentlich der, ähm, das Display ist eigentlich ganz schick, aber drei Jahre später holst du ein neues Laptop und das ist dann plötzlich schneller als das Display. Da muss man halt eben nicht mehr umschalten. Weiß nicht so genau.
Also da bin ich mir noch nicht ganz so sicher, ob das kommen wird.
Versteh schon, was du meinst, ja.
Ich sehe schon die Anwendung dafür. Das mag manchmal auch genau das sein, was man haben will.
Ja, aber da Apple ja keine Displays mehr macht, machen das ja Fremdhersteller. Die Fremdhersteller können das ja so machen, dass man das Display dann auch wieder tauschen kann.
Na ja, Apple hat angekündigt, dass sie wieder ein Display rausbringen wollen nächstes Jahr.
Ah ja, stimmt, da war irgendwas, ne?
Na, für den Mac Pro halt.
Ja, das machen sie aber bestimmt nur als unter Lizenz. Also lassen sie sich bestimmt herstellen und kleben da ihren Dings drauf. Aber sowas machen die eigentlich nicht, ne?
Na, die bauen das nicht komplett selber, aber sie definieren halt, was da drin ist und schrauben es zusammen und spezifizieren den ganzen Kram. Machen sie ja mit dem Rest auch.
Eigentlich brauchen sie ja nur einen iMac verkaufen und einfach den CPU nicht einschalten.
Nein, ich schäme das nicht. Ich rechne halt mit sowas wie 30 Zoll 8K. Na, was sonst? Was sollten sie sonst rausbringen?
Muss knallen, meinste, ja?
Naja, der neue Mac Pro wird natürlich die 8K Videomaschine sein. So, und der iMac Pro hat halt 5K. Fertig?
Man muss da nochmal toppen, die Sache.
Na, Lungen.
Stimmt schon.
Nur ein 27 Zoll Lader noch mal hinstellen, wenn sie nicht machen.
Ich habe ja immer noch das Gefühl, dass dann demnächst auch deren Laptops oder das Display vielleicht auch, dass das alles in OLED-Technik kommt. Weil alles prügeln jetzt so gnadenlos in Richtung Schwarz in letzter Zeit. Also das machen die ja nicht einfach so.
OLED? Ist wohl noch sehr teuer für große Bildschirme.
Die Frage ist ja, wo mit sie anfangen. Also die Frage ist ja, ob sie irgendwann mal so was, was jetzt das 12 Zoll MacBook ist und dein Air, das wäre vielleicht eine Größe, wo man hin will. Also ich meine, wie groß ist denn gerade? Und die iPads natürlich vorher. Aber die sind doch jetzt wahrscheinlich auch schon OLED? Oder?
Nö, also die hatten ja auch lange Zeit Probleme, OLED-Screens zu finden, die dieselbe Farbgenauigkeit hatten wie die LCDs. Also OLED hat zwar Vorteile gehabt mit dem Schwarz und so weiter und geringer Stromverbrauch und flexiblerer Bildschirmgeschichte etc. Aber Apple hat halt lange Zeit auf LCD gesetzt und tut es ja beim XR auch immer noch, weil für sie halt korrekte Farbe eines ihrer Dogmen zu sein scheint. Aber bleiben wir noch mal kurz bei Mojave. Also, ich würde ja gerne wechseln, aber ich habe jetzt echt das Problem, dass bei mir natürlich jetzt wirklich jeder Generationswechsel durchschlägt, dadurch, dass sie mich davon abgehalten haben, mir moderne Hardware zu kaufen, so lange Zeit. Weil es ja nichts gab, was man haben will. Es fallen jetzt gleich zwei iMacs komplett raus. Also, ich kann eigentlich nur meinen MacBook Air auf Mojave upgraden.
Ach so, weil deine iMacs auch kein Metall können, oder wie?
Die können kein Metall. Die sind 9 und 11. Und ab 12 geht es los. Und das Einzige, was älter ist, was noch mitziehen kann, ist halt der Mac Pro. Und von daher muss ich mir halt überlegen, was hat für mich jetzt die größere Priorität. Und ich finde halt so zwei verschiedene Versionen von Betriebssystemen zu verwenden, irgendwie, das halte ich nicht lange durch. Da gewöhnst du dich an irgendwas, und dann ist es auf dem anderen nicht. Also ich muss immer seamless zwischen meinen Rechnern hin und her wechseln können und überall dasselbe Feature Set haben, die selben Apps in der selben Version etc. Und daher muss ich jetzt irgendwas machen. Auf der anderen Seite will ich halt meine Geräte auch immer noch nicht tauschen, weil ich wüsste nicht gegen was. Die können halt Dinge, die die neuen nicht können. Und zum Beispiel mein alter 2009er iMac, der hier steht, ist halt immer noch ein zweiter Bildschirm für meinen Mac Pro. Und das ist eins der geilsten Features überhaupt. Und das gibt es halt nicht mehr. Dann müsste ich mir halt was ganz anderes einfallen lassen. Ja, ich weiß gar nicht was. Ich warte mal jetzt nochmal ab. Vielleicht kommt ja tatsächlich im Herbst nochmal irgendwas. Ich habe wenig Hoffnung, aber die stirbt ja zuletzt. Vielleicht bringen sie ja mal so Mac Mini mäßig irgendwas raus und Bildschirme. Wäre ja alles toll. Träumen, träumen, träumen.
Optimist.
Und der iMac Pro, ich habe mir das jetzt irgendwie 1000 Mal durchgerechnet, der ist mir einfach zu teuer, den brauche ich nicht. Also dafür, dass er irgendwie auch nur ein iMac ist, braucht den Speedgrad nicht und ansonsten ist da nichts drin, was ich unbedingt brauche, dieses ganze Retina. Ja, toll, wenn man es hat, will man nie wieder zurück, aber ich bin da ja noch nicht.
Du willst es nicht haben, weil du willst noch zurück.
Ja, die einzige Software, für die ich es wirklich brauche, unterstützt es irgendwie immer noch nicht.
Welche?
Maripa.
Was heißt unterstützt es nicht?
Hat nicht alles ein High DPI.
Stört mich aber persönlich nicht.
Was stört dich nicht?
Also, dass das...
Dass Maripa das nicht hat? Ja gut, aber wenn ich so einen hochauflösenden Bildschirm habe, dann möchte ich natürlich auch die maximale Auflösung haben. So, aber wenn die Software das halt nicht kann...
Gibt es da keine...
Ich weiß nicht, ich benutze das ja auch nicht mit Retina. Ich habe da keine Retina.
Sind wir ja gerade bei Luxusprobleme.
Ach du hast doch Retina. Wer hält sich denn das? Nutzt er die ganzen Pixel oder macht er da irgendwie Klötzchen?
Starte es mal gerade. Also mir ist das nicht störend aufgefallen.
Das sieht so normal aus, wie alles andere normal aussieht? Oder sieht das eine halbe Auflösung aus?
Ich glaube, es gibt so ein paar Programme, wo man mal merkt, dass ein bisschen was anders ist, aber dass es einem, selbst wenn du drüber nachdenkst, es fällt dir irgendwie nicht so krass auf. Oder geht nur mir das so?
Wie gesagt, also ist alles crisp, da sind keine gematschten Pixel oder so. Weiß nicht.
Vielleicht ist das schon weiter, als ich dachte.
Ich zeig dir mal, wie so eine Repar-Session ohne Ultraschall aussieht.
Ich hab jetzt gerade nicht den Vergleich und ich hab jetzt auch nicht die den Blick hier.
Und die Brille.
Genau. Aber das sieht für mich aus wie 1X hier, das M und so weiter, da seh ich doch von hier das Anti-Aliasing. Das sind doch alles ganz pixelige Buchstaben.
Ob wir das bei den Waveforms anders machen?
Die Waveforms, hast du das Gefühl, dass du da wirklich mal zoomen müsstest und mal richtig mal gucken, einen Screenshot machen und mal schauen, was das eigentlich für Auflösungen sind?
Also klar, es ist halt nicht Retina, das ist natürlich korrekt, aber wie gesagt, ich kann damit arbeiten.
Ich glaub, wenn du halt einmal so ein Retina-Ding hast, fällt dir das halt jetzt nicht so, also ja, es fällt dir vielleicht kurz auf, aber ich weiß nicht, dafür überwiegt der ganz andere Vorteil.
Aber warte jetzt, ich will auch noch, und zwar hier Luxusprobleme. Ich hab ja zu Hause so ein 4K-TV an der Wand und weil ich da auch ein bisschen weiter weg sitze, ich kann natürlich mein Mac, wenn ich den an den TV anschließe, nicht in 4K gucke, weil dann erkennst du ja gar nichts. Deswegen gibt's ja hier Display Preferences kannst du ja dann sagen, ja soll das halt eben als Retina darstellen, dass das halt doppelt und so, also ist das dann doppelt, ja. Also ihr wisst schon, im Retina-Modus angezeigt wird, das ist aber immer noch zu klein, ich kann das immer noch nicht so gut lesen und dann kann ich noch eine Stufe weitergehen, das ist sozusagen das Dreifache, also aus den 4K werden dann 1680 logische Pixel, also jeder Pixel besteht dann sozusagen aus neuen, echten dann stimmen die Eigens auch nicht mehr, weil Dreifacheigens gibt's halt nicht, das heißt auch meine ganze Minüber sieht dann wieder pixellig aus, weil er dafür die Zweifachen vom Retina-Modus nimmt, also das sind so meine Luxusprobleme. Das ist mein Dreifach-Retina nicht so schön auch. Ja, wollte ich mal gesagt haben. Also es wird Zeit für Vector-Grafiken, weil damit wäre das dann erledigt.
Das ist richtig. Aber jetzt kommen wir natürlich zum spannendsten Teil dieser Mojave-Debatte. Das könnte ich auch immer wieder hören.
Jetzt kommt wieder der Part für senile Mac Pro-Besitzer, die nicht loslassen können, nämlich uns.
Ja, und alle, die wir damit angesteckt haben.
Und alle, die wir damit angesteckt haben, genau. Und zwar ist es ja so, dass Mojave natürlich gewisse Hardware-Anforderungen hat, die erstmal von so einem Stock Mac Pro, also wir reden jetzt von dem 2009, 10 und 12er Modell, also die sogenannte Käse-Reibe, dass die mit der Stock-Konfiguration nicht unterstützt werden. Also sowohl die Nvidia GT120 kann kein Metal, als auch die AMD 5770 und 5870 können auch beide kein Metal. Das heißt, der Stock Mac Pro ist raus. Aber Apple hat ja jetzt auch gerade, gestern glaube ich, war es, nochmal das Support-Dokument geupdatet und sie haben nochmal was angefügt. Weil normalerweise hieß es, dass sie das, genau, das war in diesem, der hat die Liste da verlinkt oder das war da, ich glaube ganz oben genau. Das kommt mal ganz hoch.
Recommended Graphic Cards und so weiter.
Genau. Und zwar normalerweise haben die gesagt, sie unterstützen halt, das kommt mal zu der Liste. Nein, das ist nicht, ist das das Dokument? Ja, nee, das ist noch nicht das.
Das ist für die eGPUs, ne?
Ja, das ist das falsche Dokument.
Dann warst du in dem anderen Link da drüber, glaube ich. Weitergeh noch mal eins zurück.
Na ja, hier steht Any Card on this List should also work fine.
Genau, also das, was Apple gesagt hat, was geht am Mac Pro ist, wenn man halt eine Grafikkarte hat, die Metal unterstützt und dazu gehört unter anderem die Karten, die in der externen GPU halt funktionieren, weil dafür sind die Treiber da. Und das war ja die AMD, wie hießen die? Die RX 560 haben sie gesagt und dann auch RX 570 und 80, weil das, glaube ich, alles der gleiche Treiber ist. So, das ist, was zuerst in dem Support-Dokument drin stand. Und gestern kam eine Erweiterung von diesem Support-Dokument oder ein Update.
Hast du eine URL von dem Teil?
Nee, das hab ich doch, nee, hab ich nicht, sorry, sorry. Der Chat wird das bestimmt gleich ganz schnell rausschließen. Ich hab das vorhin da bei dir auch schon gesehen, war ich der Meinung. Jedenfalls ist da jetzt sozusagen so ein Appendix dran, dass sie sagen, außerdem könnten auch noch folgende Grafikkarten irgendwie mit Mojave kompatibel sein. Nämlich auch die Vega 56, die Vega 64 und dann noch hier irgendeine Fire-Dingens-Karten, wie auch immer die heißen. Genau, hier diese... Ja, AMD Frontier Edition und dann halt diese Profi-Grafikkarten, hier WX9100. Und die sind jetzt auch noch aufgelistet. Das heißt, so Leute wie ich, die jetzt halt so eine Vega 56 haben, das sieht jetzt gut aus und das sah ja auch vorher mit High-Series auch gut aus. Das könnte gehen, sagt Apple und ich kann auch sagen, es geht. Aber die Sache hat so einen kleinen Haken.
Hier ist die Liste.
Genau. Also die Original-Grafikkarten sind halt eine MSI Gaming Radeon RX 560, dann eine Zafir RX 580, noch eine Zafir HD 7950 und dann noch zwei Nvidias, nämlich die Quadro K5000 und die GeForce GTX 680 Mac Edition. So und dann kamen aber zusätzlich noch diese ganzen Radions RX 560, 570, 580, dann diese Pro-Karte WX 7100 und die RX Vega 56 und RX Vega 64.
Die sind ja im iMac Pro mit drin, ne?
Genau, deswegen sind da die Treiber da. Und für die RX 580 und so, das ist die wegen der externen GPU, wo da die Treiber kamen. Hat ja Apple schließlich dieses Developer Set da verkauft. Und die Frontier Edition, was eigentlich auch eine abgewandelte Vega-Karte irgendwie ist. So, jedenfalls aber weil diese unteren Karten da alle halt mit so einem Standard-Bios versehen sind, wovon der Mac Pro halt die Firmenwere von Mac Pro kommt, damit nicht klar.
Ich hab ja in meinem Mac Pro eine Radeon R9 280X, die ist jetzt hier überhaupt nicht aufgelistet, die ist aber trotzdem offiziell mittelsupported, laut.
Korrekt.
Aussage.
Weil diese R, was hast du gesagt? 280X. 280X ist eigentlich eine etwas schneller getaktete 7970. Das ist nämlich der gleiche Chip von Hardware her. Wurde denn von AMD nur anders benannt, das machen die sehr oft. Und dieser 7970, der steht da jetzt zwar auch nicht, das ist aber auch wieder nur die etwas mit mehr Textureinheiten getaktete Version von der 7950. Oder sagen wir so, die 7950 ist einfach eine abgeschwächte Version der 7970. Deswegen fällt alles damit in die gleiche Baustelle.
Also ich bin safe.
Du bist safe. Jedenfalls deine Karte.
Meine auch.
Und deine auch und meine auch. Das ist nämlich diese 82X. Die kann man beim Booten auch sehen, wenn man die geflasht hat. Wenn man das aber nicht gemacht hat, dann sieht man, beim Booten sieht man nichts, weil der Mac da noch kein Bild anzeigen kann auf der Karte, weil er mit der nicht klarkommt. Wenn der Treiber später geladen wurde, aber schon. Und weil Apple das auch weiß und sie ja sagen, dass diese Karten so auch so gehen könnten und sie wissen, dass man am Anfang beim Booten nichts sieht, sagen sie, Mojave ist auf diesen Karten nur supported, wenn man FileVault nicht benutzt, weil für FileVault muss man ja am Anfang sein Passwort eingeben. Und das geht dann nicht mehr. Das heißt, man kann eigentlich nicht mehr FileVault benutzen. So, ich habe das gestern extra mal den ganzen Tag getestet, habe wie ein Idiot irgendwie Mojave installiert hin und her. Und man kann das extern, das Mojave installieren, wenn man einen zweiten Rechner hat. Ich habe hier das auf meinem Mac Pro gemacht, habe die Platte sozusagen... Macbook Pro. Hab das an meinem Macbook Pro herangegangen, die Platte, habe dann Mojave installiert, dann die Platte wieder rausgenommen, wieder an den Mac Pro gesteckt und siehe da, der kann schon FileVault benutzen, wenn man eine Karte hat, die schon trotzdem am Anfang ein Bootscreen zeigt. Also so wie wir diese geflashten Karten haben. Also grundsätzlich geht es. Und sogar die Anzeige ist so, dass da nicht nur man das Passwort eingehen muss, sondern sogar das Mojave Desktop-Bild kam im Hintergrund, was früher auch nicht der Fall war. Also das ist jetzt durch die neue Firma, da kommen wir gleich hin. Also so grundsätzlich geht das. Das heißt, wenn ihr euer Filevolt behalten wollt, müsst ihr das woanders installieren als auf dem Mac Pro. Und dann geht es auch.
Das Lokal ist nichts.
Alter, die kommst du dann nach Hause, machen dir deine Tür auf und nehmen deinen Rechner mit und bumm, weg ist er. Und dann haben die deine Daten, ich sag jetzt nicht wer.
Hast ja recht.
Ich hab auch überlegt, ja Filevolt, bevor ich jetzt die Platte da rüber schleppe, ich weiß nicht, ich könnte sie auch einfach ausmachen, also es dauert natürlich auch eine Weile. Dann dachte ich, nee irgendwie vom Gefühl her, 2018, meine Daten liegen nicht fucking unverschlüsselt auf irgendwie der Platte rum. Das mach ich schon seitdem es Filevolt gibt nicht mehr und das macht man einfach nicht. Und ich glaube, es ist auch eine gute Einstellung und die habe ich mir beibehalten. Das ist okay so. Und es geht ja auch weiter. Also ihr könnt das einschalten. Und dank AES-NI mit euren Prozessoren flutscht das auch, weil die Hardware in der CPU das macht. Ihr merkt das speedmäßig gar nichts. Also ihr könnt das wirklich getrost einschalten. So, das wäre erstmal der folgende Teil. That's Firmware.
Nee, Moment, warte, Moment.
Komm, Norbert.
Du hast jetzt gesagt, du hast extern installiert und ist denn jetzt das Fazit, wenn wir eine Karte haben, die Bootscreen, geflasht, kompatibel, etc. ist, muss man nicht die Platte ausbauen, um das abzudaten?
Weil der Mojave Installer sagt, du kannst nur installieren, wenn du Metal hast und keinen Filevolt.
Okay, aber in dem Moment...
Angenommen, du hättest jetzt, du hast es ja nicht, aber angenommen, du hättest Filevolt, das funktioniert alles, aber er lässt es sich einfach nicht installieren auf dem Rechner selbst. Dann nimmst du die Platte raus, installierst das woanders.
Das gilt aber nur für die Bootdisk, nicht für irgendwelche Platten, die Filevolt haben.
Ja, es geht nur für das Installieren von dem Mojave selbst. Nur für den Vorgang an sich zählt es. Es funktioniert ja alles, nur er lässt es sich auf dem Mac Pro nicht installieren.
Also Bootdisk muss ohne Filevolt sein.
Genau. Der Rest muss nicht, muss nur woanders installieren, dann geht's.
Also du nimmst die Platte mit Filevolt raus, steckst die an deinen Macbook Pro, gibst dein Filevolt-Passwort ein, sagst dem Installer hier bitte einmal da lang.
Fertig installiert, wieder zurück in Mac Pro und alles funktioniert mit Filevolt und so weiter. Nur der Installiervorgang will dich das nicht machen lassen, weil sie Angst haben, dass du eine Grafikkarte hast, wo du das Filevolt-Passwort am Anfang nicht eingeben kannst. Das ist deren Angst.
Okay.
Bisschen berechtigt natürlich.
Jetzt hab ich jetzt aktuell noch kein Filevolt aktiviert, das werd ich natürlich in Kürze dann gleich machen. Aber dann lässt ein Installer das auch auf dem Mac Pro update.
Ja, müsste gehen. Kannst du ja dann berichten, aber eigentlich muss das gehen. Metal musst du haben und Filevolt auf. Und das ist ja dann gegeben. Dann die nächste erfreuliche Geschichte. Zumindest so ein bisschen aktuell erfreulich. Und so ein bisschen gibt's einem Hoffnung für die Zukunft. Und zwar schon zu High Sierra Zeiten gab's für den Mac Pro öfter Firmenbeupdates. Und zwar, seitdem das hier mit Intel, mit Spectre und Meltdown gewesen ist, brauchte man ja Microcode-Updates. Und da ging's dann schon los, dass da tatsächlich auch welche gekommen sind mit irgendwelchen Zwischenversionen von High Sierra. Und zwar, wenn man hier in seinen Mac Pro guckt. Du hast gesagt, 84 hattest du gesagt, ne? Von deiner Firma? Ja, war 84, genau. Ich glaub, das war so die erste, die rauskam in den Betas von High Sierra. Gab's noch ein bisschen ältere. Aber das, was man dann haben sollte, war 84. Und inzwischen gibt's aber auch schon 87 und ich glaube dann 89. Das kommt aber nicht, wenn man nur High Sierra updatet. Das kommt nur, wenn man einen Clean-Install macht, weil sie das vorher meinen, lohnt sich sonst nicht oder irgendwie so. Aber eigentlich ist der aktuelle für High Sierra, wer 89. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie die gesamte Versionsdring ist, aber der wichtige Teil ist das mit der 89. Das heißt, da sind mehrere Firmware-Updates gekommen, die dann den neueren Micro-Code drin haben von Intel, aber auch noch nicht den ganz neuesten. Also wer die 89 hatte, hat die Micro-Codes von April zurück, und danach gab es noch mal im Juni welche. Hat ja doch sehr gerüttelt mit dem Spectre und Meltdown. Und dann aber ist erstaunlicherweise für Mojave, kam noch mal ein Firmware-Update, was erstens die allerneuesten Intel Micro-Code-Updates von Juni drin hat. Also man hat dann mit Mojave, mit der Firmware, die neuesten Micro-Code-Updates. Und aber auch dieser Trick, dass man bei den Grafikkarten irgendwie so einen Widerstand auslöten musste, den sogenannten R17, damit man halt diese fünf Gigatransactions pro Sekunde hat. Das dient irgendwie für die Erkennung zwischen PCI-Version 3 und PCI-Version 2. Das ist wahrscheinlich auch ein Bug in der Firmware gewesen, weswegen man das so oder mit dem Widerstand da tricksen konnte, dass sie dir dann doch erkennt, die Karte. Das ist nicht mehr nötig, sondern die Karte erkennt jetzt ordentlich, also die Firmware erkennt jetzt ordentlich PCI-Version 3-Karten, obwohl der Mac Pro ja nur PCI-Version 2 hat und passt dann diese Transferrate an, sodass man jetzt auch fünf Gigatransactions pro Sekunde hat und nicht mehr nur zweieinhalb. Also ihr beide habt diesen Widerstand ja nicht ausgelöst, weil das so ein Fummelkram ist, und man muss den erstmal finden irgendwie auf der Platine. Und das heißt, für euch würde das dann automatisch, hättet ihr dann diese fünf Gigatransactions. Wenn man so Ballerspiele spielt, wo man ja die FPS wichtig sind, man hat dann so zwei, drei, vier Prozent, sind die dann ein bisschen schneller. Also es ist nicht viel, aber es ist für Nix tun sozusagen durch Software gefixt. Also wir haben das mal gefixt. Und dann ist wohl auch noch was mit HDMI-Sound von diesen Karten, weil die haben ja auch Audio über HDMI. Da ist wohl auch noch irgendwie ein Bucket fix, aber damit mache ich nicht so viel, deswegen kann ich das nicht so genau nachdenken. Ja, da soll wohl auch eine Verbesserung gekommen sein. So, das war mit Mojave. Und die haben den Versionsstring von der Firmware auch angepasst. Und zwar ist der jetzt so wie beim allerneuesten iMac Pro irgendwie. Und zwar heißt der bei Mojave jetzt 138.0.0.0.0. Der ist jetzt ein bisschen anders. Das heißt, die sitzen wirklich da und machen gerade die Firmware moderner. Was noch anders war, ist, dass sie sich, dass man keine EFI-Grafikkarte mehr brauchte, um das flashen zu können, sondern das geht jetzt irgendwie auch ohne. Das ist irgendwie wahrscheinlich sehr technisch jetzt, aber...
Um was flashen zu können?
Diese Firmware. Vor allem musste man mit einer EFI-Grafikkarte booten, damit man das Mac Pro sich flashen konnte. Das ist jetzt nicht mehr so. Das ist irgendwie besser geworden. Das ist sehr technisch, aber man merkt da dran, dass gerade die Firmware und auch den Flash-Prozess an sich, wie man die Firmware flasht, also das Flash-Programm wurde geupdatet, dass da richtig viel passiert, gerade im Firmware-Bereich. Auch noch für den Mac Pro, der seit neun Jahren existiert.
Aber wenn ich das richtig verstehe, ich hab ja jetzt noch eine alte Firmware und ich kriege deshalb die nicht hier rauf, weil ich ja nur Updates gemacht habe und die müsste quasi frisch installieren. Wenn ich jetzt diesen Trick mache mit Mojave, auf einen anderen Rechner drauf installieren, hätte ich das ja dann immer noch nicht.
Das stimmt, aber du könntest ja den Mojave Installer auf dem Mac Pro runterladen, schließt irgendeine leere SSD oder USB Stick oder was auch immer an.
Ich hab ja das Firewall noch nicht an, also brauch ich das ja gar nicht. Ich könnte das einfach direkt hier installieren und dann müsste im Prinzip in dem Prozess auch die neueste Firmware draufladen.
Aber der Mojave Installer sagt am Anfang, du musst diese Firmware haben. Das ist sozusagen der erste Schritt, den er will. Und das heißt, du kannst den erstmal ausführen. Der installiert dann die neue Firmware und danach machst du einfach die Installation von Mojave nicht, falls du gar keinen Mojave haben willst. Also man kann sozusagen das einfach nur nutzen, um nur die Firmware erstmal so zu bekommen, ohne dass man das Mojave installiert. Weil er bootet ja danach mit hier, du musst den Button festhalten, bis die Lampe blinkt am Mac Pro. Dann fängt er auch kurz an zu piepen und dann legt er los, update er sich und wenn er damit fertig ist, dann sagst du einfach ne, danke, ich will nicht weiter installieren. Genau, kann's gehen.
Okay, macht ja schon mal Sinn, das schon mal runterzuladen hier.
Genau. Das nächste Ding ist, dass gerade gestern, weil ich ja so viel mit hier Mac Pro und Mojave und probieren und testen und so ein 5V-Rum experimentiert habe, habe ich wieder geguckt, hier bei Mac Rumors ist immer so ein Typ, in der neuesten Mojave 10.14.1 Beta, die gestern oder vorgestern schon rauskam, ist schon wieder eine neue Firma für den Mac Pro drin, nämlich die 139.00. Da haben sie aber festgestellt, keine weiteren neuen Änderungen, also hat sich irgendwie gar nichts geändert, aber anscheinend haben sie die Versionen hochgezählt, weil irgendwas haben sie doch geändert. Also die sind da am machen.
Das finde ich jetzt wirklich spannend, dass sie sich so um den alten Mac Pro kümmern.
Ich finde das auch spannend und vor allem diese Jungs da, diesen Forum, kleben ja diesen NVMe-Treiber aus irgendeinem anderen Rechner einfach da rein, weil das EFI-Firma ist auch so modularisiert. Man kann einfach so Module so reinwerfen, die werden dann so erkannt irgendwie automatisch und dann vom Mac Pro oder so haben sie den NVMe-Teil, also da mit von NVMe-Booten kannst du da reingeschmissen. Das heißt, der Mac Pro gepatcht kann von NVMe booten und das geht auch immer noch auch mit dieser 139, 138 und so weiter.
Na, soll Apple auch mal einbauen?
Na, da warten wir ja drauf, weil was Apple machen muss, ist ja nichts weiter als dieses Modul nehmen und reinfallen lassen, so 5 Minuten Job und das einfach deployen und fertig. Also das wäre ja...
Mit Code von den Hackern?
Nee, das ist ihren eigenen Code, sie müssen es nur reinfallen lassen.
Wie ist das ihr eigener Code?
Das ist ein NVMe Modul vom iMac oder irgendwie so.
Ach so, vom OS, den sie quasi in die Firmware reinschmeißen müssten. Ach so, vom iMac, ach so, weil sie das da...
Von der Firmware mit dem iMac, da ist NVMe drin und die Hacker haben das Modul genommen und verändert.
Also ein iMac Pro meinst du?
Oder ein normaler iMac, irgendwie ein modernerer Max, welcher auch immer das gewesen ist, haben das Modul genommen, lassen das da in die Firmware fallen und boom, es funktioniert. Kein Code-Änderung, kein gar nichts, nur so ein Modul genommen und reinfallen lassen, da wo Platz ist. Weil die sind ja nie voll, diese Firmware-Files, also dieses Flash-Files. Das ist immer so 8 MB oder 16 MB, weißt schon. Da ist Platz und dann schmeißen sie das da rein und dann wird es automatisch erkannt, weil EFI so modularisiert ist und so weiter. Okay.
Und was heißt, sie schmeißen das da rein?
Ja, so eine Lippe irgendwie mit reingeschmissen ins EFI-File.
Also sie laden es...
Dann checkt sie mal neu berechnet und reingeflesht. Fertig. Also wirklich gar keinen Hack drin, kein Code umgeschrieben, kein gar nichts, nur so ein Modul mit dazu geklebt. Weil EFI sehr...
Modulare...
Genau, ist ja von Intel irgendwie erfunden vor wann auch immer. Und das, ja genau. Da sind lauter so Treiber drin, die da so modulmäßig irgendwie so reingelegt werden. Und viel anderes. Und die Maiko-Codes ja auch. Also die haben ja auch da eine Weile lang sogar die Maiko-Codes reingepatcht und so, weil da auch so ein Modul ist, wo die Maiko-Codes drin sind. Mich wundert ja immer noch, warum, wenn die das mit den Maiko-Codes schon so können, warum immer noch keiner Support für modernere CPUs, wie im Mac Pro auch für den Xsurf gemacht hat, weil dem fehlt ja der Maiko-Code für diese moderneren CPUs. Also für diese...
Ja, ich glaube Xsurf interessiert einfach wirklich keinen.
Mir ist gerade einer angeboten worden.
Na welcher? Der allerneueste, allerletzte rechts unten Xsurf? Ich guck mal. Also nimm den mal, weil, wenn demnächst dann doch irgendwann einer diesen Maiko-Code-Patch da macht, dann kann man da die dicke CPU mit dem AIS-Support und so weiter rein...
Ich brauch echt keinen Xsurf. Also das Ding ist mir wirklich zu...
Aber Harald Welter hat für den Xsurf geschrieben, dass die LEDs da so blinken, wie die CPU-Auslastung ist. Schon vor 10 Jahren. Ich hab gegoogelt, wie ich diese LED rankriege, und dann sehe ich, dass das einer unter Intel gemacht hat, und dann gucke ich, ah, Harald Welter. Ist egal, da passiert eine Menge. Die Hacker beobachten das mit Lupe. Also die sind wirklich da voll dabei, nehmen da alles auseinander, wenn da eine neue Firmware rauskommt. Und man kann nur hoffen, dass die bei Apple doch noch irgendwann genädig sind, und zum Beispiel das NVMe sagen, ey Jungs, komm, hier, hab das, funktioniert ja anscheinend, auf eure Verantwortung macht, was ihr wollt oder irgendwie so. Das könnten sie ja mindestens dann machen, wenn die Kisten abgeschrieben sind. Sie können sagen, hier, jetzt hier, habt ihr den Scheiß, mach doch einfach. Also das wär schon ziemlich cool von NVMe zu booten, weil dann hast du auch plötzlich irgendwie mal so 3 GB die Sekunde booten wollen.
Das wär richtig geil, da könnte man die Slots nochmal richtig gut zum Einsatz bringen und die Kiste wär gleich nochmal flinker. Wobei der ist mir eh flink genug. Absurd, wie viel Hub das Ding hat.
Also mein Laptop ist schneller als mein Mac Pro. Deutlich.
Aber er hat trotzdem, also...
Der ist schon bumm, so Grafik ist, Power ist schon geil. Und auch, dass da so viele Platten reingehen.
Auch alles, was wirklich Multicore ist, ist...
Auch der ist schneller...
.atmet das Teil weg.
Nee.
Schneller als mein Mac Pro?
Naja, du hast jetzt nochmal doppelt so. Du hast ja 12 CPUs so. Wird es ein bisschen schwierig. Was?
Wie ist mein Mac Pro? Ist schneller als dein Laptop?
Aber ich würde sagen, der Sechskerne Laptop, der vor zwei Wochen rauskam oder wann das war, vor drei Wochen, habt ihr über den mal geredet eigentlich?
Nee, nix.
Der könnte auch schneller sein als deiner.
Ey nix, ich hab V8.
V12. Ja, V12 hast du.
V24.
Deine modernen japanischen Kawasaki-Maschinen. Ich hab hier richtig amerikanischen Hubraum.
Ich geh mal zu Geekbench und guck mal, ob dein Ding weggeblasen wird.
Ob der schneller ist oder nicht, das ist ja die eine Frage.
Geht um andere Sachen nicht gleich.
Der Mac Pro hat keine Touchbar, der Mac Pro hat vier Fettsplattenslots, der Mac Pro hat so einige.
Nicht nur vier, du hast ja noch die beiden, wo die optischen Laufwerke sind.
Ich hab 48 Gigabyte.
Ja, und das auch noch. Aber eine Leseart wäre natürlich auch, wenn sie sich jetzt noch um den alten Mac Pro kümmern, dass der neue noch eine ganze Weile brauchen wird und sie jetzt ihre ganzen Pro-User, die immer noch auf den alten Mac Pros hängen, nicht ganz im Ring stehen lassen wollen.
Das ist eigentlich ganz cool, ja.
Also das MacBook Pro hat hier... Ach so, wir müssen ja... Du willst Multicore testen natürlich, ja. Ich guck mal.
Ist egal. Ich weiß ja, warum ich meinen Mac Pro mag. Ich hab dir übrigens den Link zu dem XSurf geschickt. Kannst mir mal sagen, ob du den haben willst.
Ja, for free auf jeden Fall.
Ehrlich?
Klar. Ich hab auch schon... Ich hab ja noch einen XSurf Power PC zu Hause. Den hat jemand, den wir beide sehr lange kennen.
Also willst du den haben?
Also, den Power PC hab ich auch genommen. Das war der letzte seiner Art. Und ich hab da Freebies deinstalliert und es rockt. Ist ein bisschen laut, okay?
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das Ding ist wirklich einer der lautesten Maschinen, aber eine der schönsten. Wenn nicht sogar der schönste Server.
MacBook Pro, das neueste, Mitte 2018, 22.500 Punkte bei Geekbench und der schnellste Mac Pro, so wie Tim den hat, 20.000.
Naja, ist doch aber geil für so eine alte Maschine.
Was? 20.000 was?
Euro? Geekbench-Punkte.
Ach so.
Das heißt, das letzte MacBook Pro von Mitte 2018 ist noch mal schneller als dein Mac Pro. Zehn Prozent. Was haben die denn? Die haben nur maximal 32. Du hast 64?
48.
Wir müssen hier immer so Quartettkarten einführen. RAM-Ausbau, erster Stecher.
Ja.
Ja, das Einzige wirklich, was ich an diesem Mac Pro vermisse, ist jetzt doch dann auch das Thunderbolt-Interface. Das wär geil, aber das kommt ja nicht mehr.
Nee, das kommt nicht mehr. Aber USB 3 gibt es ja auch in kompatibel mit geht und so.
Ja, aber USB 3 ist halt nicht 3.1.
Und ich glaub, da gibt es auch, da brauchst du auch ein Modul, damit du von USB 3 booten kannst, damit das beim Booten auch schon erkannt wird. Und das kann man glaube ich auch so reinschmeißen, wenn man will, weil das auch wieder so ein Standard-Apple-Firmware, weißt schon, so reinoperiert irgendwie und geht, wenn es dich schon vielleicht sogar ohne das geht.
USB 3?
Bei der Versionsnummer bleibt die gleiche, das heißt, wenn eine neue Firmware kommt und man die installiert, dann fällt das zwar weg, aber macht trotzdem ein normalen Update und dann muss man die Module wieder reinschmeißen.
Genau, der macht das Update dann drüber, weil das nicht checkt, aber dann nimmst du das wieder und musst die Module wieder reinschmeißen. Und der Mac Pro kann ja von alleine nicht updaten, der muss dann drücken, bevor der updatet.
Und ich pimpt mir den Mac Pro.
Aber weißt du, das finde ich dann wiederum erstaunlich, da bist du bereit, hier so zu investieren und dann dir den Dennis nochmal kommen zu lassen, um dir deinen Cheese Grater aufzupolieren, aber ein FreeBSD Fileserver, das geht nicht, oder wie? Ich weiß, die Hardware ist nicht so sexy. Die Software ist auch nicht so sexy.
Die Hardware muss schon sexy sein.
Aber dann nimm du doch den Xserver mit.
Nee, der ist mir zu laut, das ist nicht sexy.
Aber also, ja. Oropax und dann...
Ich hab das erstmal auf dem Backburner. Das ist nicht weg, aber es hat ja auch nicht gedrängt oder so. Da es jetzt keinen hier obvious Winner gab, steht das erstmal wieder hinten an.
Gut, naja, also, das ist schon mal gut zu wissen, dass es einen Upgrade-Part gibt. Dann warte ich jetzt mal den üblichen Monat oder zwei, bis sich das ganze Audio-Universum auch geklärt hat, ob es denn mit Mojave einwandfrei spielen mag.
Das ist immer wieder echt die totale Archivist-Ferse. Und ich weiß immer nicht so richtig, an wem es eigentlich jetzt wirklich liegt. Also, schon klar, Apple baut da auch Sachen ein und da ist nicht immer alles gut gelaufen, aber ich bin mir auch immer nicht so sicher, ob der Fehler wirklich immer bei Apple liegt.
Also, mein Audio-Interface bei Moto 2 sind es ja glaube ich immer ganz fresh mit den Treibern. Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass in Wirklichkeit die ganzen Plug-Ins vermutlich eher Probleme haben, wenn sie als Audio-Unit verwendet werden. Aber da Reaper ja VST und VST3-Effekte oder Plug-Ins auch unterstützt und AAX und wie sie nicht alle heißen, ist das vielleicht in Wirklichkeit auch gar kein Problem. Nur wenn man jetzt die mit Logic verwenden würde, wollen wir Garage Band vielleicht.
So, haben wir den Mac durchgepimpt?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Letty, du auch? Alles klar? Irgendwie, weißt du, was du machen musst jetzt?
Machst du eigentlich auch einen Mac Pro oder müssen wir da noch einen besorgen?
Ich hab gerade gesehen, hier bei meinem Dealer, wo ich meinen Mac gekauft hab, da gibt's gerade den 5.1 oder sogar den, warte mal, den 4, ne, ne, ne, den, die aus München, da gibt's gerade einen für 689, aber schon mit der ATI 5870, einer Terabyte SATA-Platte.
Aber die brauchen wir ja nicht mehr, die Karte.
Ach so, das ist die alte, das ist nicht unsere, ja.
Ne, ne, du brauchst die.
Naja, anyway, es gibt jetzt den, also ich glaub, für ungefähr 600 hab ich meinen damals auch gekauft und dann gepimpt für noch mal 200 oder 300. Unter 1000 wird die billiger als das iPhone X. Macht aber schön warm im Winter.
Und man hat noch das Gefühl, wenn der Rechner gerade Scheiß macht, dass man auch ab und zu mal so unterm Tisch so gegen treten kann, weil, du Sau.
Reißt dir die Meter-Ebene nicht ein.
Ja, aber da kann man so ein bisschen, das ist halt robust, da kann man auch mal so ein bisschen basteln und hinlegen und operieren und machen und tun. Und wenn er läuft, dann läuft er erstmal.
Das Ding ist echt so, das hab ich früher halt auch gemacht, aber ich hab da nicht mehr so, also ich hab genug andere Habis, glaub ich.
Ich hab meinen Mac Pro da, ich weiß gar nicht, das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich auch im Archiv der Freak Show für immer festgehalten, wann ich meinen Mac Pro mir gekauft hab, aber das ist jetzt bestimmt auch zwei Jahre her mindestens. Als ich den Job gewechselt hab, und den hab ich nur einmal hier so nach Gusto Dennis quasi gepimpt. Nach der original Dennis-Arens-Freak Show-Pimp-Vorlage.
Erzähl mir mehr, Hucke!
Seitdem musste ich da nicht wieder ran. Mehr Festplatten reinschlecken.
Und du benutzt den aktiv?
Ja, wenn ich im Homeoffice bin. Mein Main-Rechner. Darauf zocke ich Minecraft, darauf zocke ich alle anderen Spiele.
Und fettes Display auch angeschlossen.
27 Zoll. 4K.
Ich erfreue mich hier mit meinem MacBook Pro.
Hast du dein großes Display zu Hause?
Nee, hab ich in der Tat auch nicht.
Also du hast nur den Rechner und das wars?
Nee, ich hab zwei Rechner. Ich hab das MacBook Pro, den noch guten, in late 2013. Und ich hab die Kackmöhre von Arbeit.
Ach, das mit dem Touchbar-Scheiß.
Der mir ständig halt rumzickt. Genau, ich hab den kleinen. Aber das Einzige ist, wenn ich mir wirklich jetzt zeitnah irgendwas holen müsste, dann wäre es nur etwas Kleineres, was leichter ist, weil ich merke gerade, der ist einfach zu schwer mittlerweile.
Mach mal ein bisschen mehr Sport.
Noch mehr Sport als Letty geht gerade gar nicht.
Bist du gerade im Volltraining?
Da können wir ja irgendwann anderes drüber reden, mit dem Mikrofone nicht anzuhören. Aber was Leichteres, ich meine, mich nervt das schon, dass der, wenn man den mit ins Bett nimmt, ist der schon etwas schwerfällig. Also mein Homeoffice ist halt...
Da liegt ja schon das Telefon.
Gibt es bestimmt so Pokémon-Telefon-Schlüpfer?
Eine Minute, dann ist das da voll.
Ja, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich.
Genau, jetzt sucht man die passenden Pokémon-Telefonschlüpfer fürs S-Ära.
Nee, also ich finde Standrechner, das passt für mich halt nicht, weil ich halt, selbst wenn ich im Homeoffice bin, irgendwie so, ich sag mal, dass ich also drei Stationen in meinem Homeoffice-Zimmer habe, wenn ich mich halt lang, nicht langweile, aber wenn ich dann irgendwie...
Ja, Konti... wie heißt das? Ich kann es immer nicht aussprechen. Konti... Konti... wie heißt das? Kontinuiti. Kontinuiti, genau. Achso, dafür musst du Bluetooth anmachen. Und dann noch in der iCloud sowieso deine ganzen Sachen ablegst, dann kannst du auf jeder Station ein Rechner positionieren. Und egal, wo du dich hinsetzt, ist immer alles da.
Ein Mac Pro in jedem Raum.
Wo wir gerade bei Kontinuiti sind. Ich hab noch einen Nachtrag für Pimp My Mac, also für Mac Pro Geschichte.
Das ist immer noch ein Pimp My Mac-Segment.
Okay, also weitere Pimp-Vorlage. Und zwar... Jetzt hab ich schon wieder die nächsten. Erstmal Keks einschmeißen.
Nüsse.
Nüschen.
Und zwar bei Mac Pro diese Kontinuiti-Features und Hand-Off. Bei manchen Leuten gehen die ja nicht. Ich weiß nicht, ob es bei dir geht, Hucke.
Manchmal.
Beides oder eins von beiden nicht. AirDrop geht, aber Kontinuiti zum Beispiel mit Copy und Paste mit dem Telefon geht nicht.
Also es geht, wenn ich hier den Browser gerade aufhabe auf dem Telefon und dann Apfel-Tapf auf dem Mac Pro mache, dann zeigt er mir dann auch den Safari-Browser an. Ist das dann Hand-Off?
Dann ist bei dir schon mal gut. Bei mir geht das nämlich nicht mehr, aber AirDrop geht schon noch. Alle setzen natürlich diese eingepimmte Bluetooth-Card drauf.
Ja klar, voll eingesprungen, eingepimmte.
Aber das wisst ihr aus Sendungen, wo wir dich schon mehrmals erwähnt haben. Jedenfalls, der Typ, der gerade das hier mit dieser Firmware und so rausgefunden hat, der ist auch voll jetzt der, also er ist gar nicht so der Hacker, aber er trägt sich auch alle Informationen zusammen und nimmt das so auseinander. Und der meint auch, dass die Firmware, du kannst nicht einfach dieses File nehmen und in diesen Mac Pro reinflaschen, sondern der Flasher, der das macht, trägt auch sogenannte Device-IDs und Hardware-IDs oder so in diese Firmware ein. Und da gibt es so drei verschiedene Sachen, also auch wie Seriennummer und so. Also die sind sozusagen angepasst, diese Firmwares, die da reingeflasht werden. Und das geht aber ab und zu schief, weil der Flasher von Apple auch sehr scheiße ist. Und dann steht da sozusagen einfach 0000 drin als Wert. Und wenn du diese Device-IDs in deiner Firmware nicht hast und Apple benutzt die aber, um gegenseitig zu Continuity und Handoff zu machen, dann fallen diese Features einfach weg. Und das ist die Vermutung, dass Apple das mit aufgenommen hat für diese Features, weil die Hackintosh-Leute diese Werte ja nicht haben und die das dann nicht benutzen können. Also die vermuten, dass das so um die Hackintosh-Leute zu ärgern ist. So, jedenfalls war das bei Apple aber auch ab und zu nicht klappt. Kann das ein Grund sein, also das kann der Grund dafür sein, dass es ab und zu nicht funktioniert. Und der Witz ist, dass der Typ immer in der Leute sind, sagen, ja bei mir geht aber hier Continuity nicht. Dann sagt der mal, ja liest doch mal dein Original Firmware aus und schick mir die, da gibt es auch schon Tools, die das auslesen in diesem Recovery-Modus, wo du dann herankommst und so. Da hat einer so ein Firmware-Dump-Tool geschrieben, dass du das auslesen kannst. Dann sagt der, schick mir das, dann guckt der da rein, guckt nach, ob da wirklich irgendwie nichts drinsteht. Lässt sich dann die richtigen Werte geben, die auf dem Rechner stehen oder woher auch die dann kommen. Trägt dir dann ein, schickt dem das zurück, du flashst das rein und danach geht dann Continuity wieder. Also wer da Probleme hat und das unbedingt haben will, der müsste mal bei MacRumors den entsprechenden Post suchen, den ich jetzt, ich hab ja keinen Slack, deswegen Hucke, musst du das gleich machen.
Wieso hast du eigentlich keinen Slack?
Weil entweder der Huckel oder die Leute, die hier daneben sind.
Keinen Slack haben ist auch scheiße.
Nee, aber weniger als Slack zu haben, deswegen bevorzuge ich das.
Warum, warum?
Schick mir einfach eine iMessage mit der Huckel.
Na, ich kann nur jetzt hier...
Dennis, wir haben dich jetzt wieder dazu bekommen, eine Sendung zu hören, dann wirst du auch noch was Slack installieren können.
Nur dreiviertel, die letzte Stunde habe ich nicht geschafft.
Reicht mir, kannst ja erst mal dreiviertel Slack installieren.
Wie kann ich jetzt diesen Link hier rüberschieben? Ah nee, ich muss erst AirDrop machen. So, jetzt kann ich doch den hier so rüberschieben, oder nicht?
Probieret. Thirteen ist mein Computer.
Und jettet? Und den kannst du jetzt in Slack schmeißen. Wir können das ja mal automatisieren, dann kann ich fragen, wann.
Mach mal einen schönen Automator-Shortcut. Da ist der Post.
Ordentliche Automierung.
Der Typ, der mit diesem Bild da auch, das ist der, der das gerade alles auseinandernimmt und sich da voll kümmert und voll Support macht. Also der ist gerade der Held der MacPro-Szene. Einmal Applaus für, wie auch immer der heißt. Na, so Held werden ja gebraucht.
TSI Alex heißt der.
Genau, die wirklich alle Informationen von anderen zusammenschustern und alles schön auch dokumentieren ordentlich hinschreiben, alle Fragen beantworten, den Leuten weiterhelfen und so. Der ist sozusagen gerade der Hub der MacPro-Hacking-Szene. Also was die Firmware betrifft gerade. Find ich voll gut auf jeden Fall.
Ich frag mich ja ernsthaft, wie lange diese MacPros insgesamt noch so leben werden.
Also die haben ja schon ordentlich Bums, weil es wirklich gute Hardware ist. Also ein paar Jahre macht es schon noch.
Ja, ich meine, jetzt haben sie fast... Wann kam der erste raus?
2009.
Nee.
Der erste?
Also jetzt grundsätzlich diese Hardware-Form.
Intel mit Cheese Grater.
Oder genau dein Inhalt auch.
Nee, Intel mit 2007 oder so.
Das war doch schon die G5 hatten, das war doch schon...
Nee, nee, mit Intel.
Ach so, dann 2006 direkt. 2006 oder 2007, musst du auch gleich...
Mac Pro 2006 hatte der schon Intel... Ja, 2006.
Aber die kriegt man ja, die ganz alten kriegt man jetzt auch nicht mehr so richtig. Das ist jetzt doch schon nur noch beschränkt auf die 2009er, oder?
Ja, die alten haben...
3.1, 4.1 und 5.1 gibt's immer noch so auf dem Markt.
Ja, aber 3.1 kann das ja, der ist ja rausgefallen. Da gibt's ja auch 2.1 und 1.1, da haben sie auch eine Weile so rumgehackt und Sachen gemacht. Aber die können halt das aktuelle Zeug nicht mehr fahren, die sind relativ schnell.
Ok, also im Prinzip März 2009 mit dem 4.1er. So, das heißt, nächsten März...
10 Jahre Mac Pro.
10 Jahre Mac Pro irgendwie läuft immer noch und wird immer noch frisch gepimpt und Leute bohren sich da irgendwie durch die Kurve.
Und bootet von NVMe, das gab's vor 10 Jahren sicher schon auch, aber... Na, es gibt meistens alles länger als man denkt, nur halt noch nicht im Markt.
Nein.
Also jedes Mal, wenn ich sowas hab, wo ich denke, oh, ist ja voll neu, guckste nach, und dann haben die das schon standardisiert, als ich noch in den Windeln lag. Ja, ist oft so.
Ja guck mal, Dennis, hier sucht noch einer, das ist auch eine schöne, äh, Dinglisch-Fizierung, hier sucht jemand einen, der seine CPUs delidet.
Ja, hier, da hast du auch hier das Dir machen lassen von jemanden, das kannst du doch da weitervermitteln zur Not. Hans Solo.
Ja, das ist alles eine Frage von Föhn und Kraft.
Mut.
Okay, 2011 kam NVMe raus. Du hast recht, ein bisschen später als tatsächlich die Lex und die Booten jetzt.
Aber du hast auch recht, ich dachte, das gibt's doch nicht so lang.
Aber machen wir dann so eine LAN-Party, wo wir dann alle unsere Mac-Pros dann zusammen bestellen und dann irgendwie, weiss nicht, Minecraft-Multiplayer übers LAN spielen. Oder wie hieß das Spiel? Halo? War das auf dem Mac? Nee, von Bungie dieses...
Ich weiß, dass immer Opa erzählt vom Krieg, das ging ganz schnell, aber ich habe damals ja drei Amigas über Flip verbunden, über Flip und Slip. Parallel-Line-Interface, Protokoll-Line-Interface und so weiter. Also einen anderen Amiga mit Slip angeschlossen, einen anderen mit Flip. Und dann haben wir zu dritt Spaceward Ho gespielt über so ein Netzwerk-Protokoll von Commodore, das hieß irgendwie Envoy, also die meinten, sie müssten das Internet selber erfinden. Das lief aber so grundsätzlich. Und dann bei Spaceward Ho ist ja so Move-Based oder Turn-Based heißt das, immer nur ein Zug, aber der wurde halt automatisch über dieses Ding da übertragen, weil es glaube ich einfach nur in einem Pfeil gespeichert wurde. Und dann haben wir zu dritt Spaceward Ho gespielt mit drei Rechnern. Das war damals Rocket Science, also... 90er, Mitte der 90er irgendwann, keine Ahnung.
Ich bin mit Token Ring eingestiegen.
Nee, da ist das alles an mir vorbei gerutscht. Und dann gleich TCP.
So, jetzt machen wir mal zu dem Pimp-Bereich. Hat sich jetzt ausgepimpt.
Schalten wir die Muckellampe wieder aus.
Pimpt, aber da kommt bestimmt noch mehr.
Ich wollte noch auf ein kleines Projekt hinweisen, was einfach nur schön ist. Und zwar... Ihr kennt doch alle den Rubik's Cube, ne? Den tollen Zauberwürfel. Kann den jemand von euch?
Ich hab den einmal...
Nee, ich kann also aktuell nicht, aber ich hab zu Hause die Original-Spiegel-Anleitung in der Kopie von Original-Digel von damals. Wartest du sie mal? Ich konnt es mal. Und ich kann auch die... Na langsam natürlich. Wie schnell? Keine Ahnung, ein Minute oder länger. Also zwei wahrscheinlich, drei, keine Ahnung.
Ich hab das einmal ohne irgendwelche Cheats und so, aber ich hab einfach wochenlang da dran rumgedreht. Echt? Bis er irgendwann...
Ich hatte mal eine richtig heiße Phase, ich glaub mein Rekord ist 29 Sekunden oder so.
Boah, ich war mal so gefrostet, dass ich die Dinger umgeklebt habe.
Wieso umgeklebt? Du kannst sie doch abmachen und einfach umstecken.
Rausbrechen und umstecken.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob ich's... Ja, vielleicht hab ich da auch eine Mischung daraus gemacht, das weiß ich nicht mehr, aber ich weiß, dass ich irgendwann mal...
Das ist gar nicht so schwierig mit diesem Rubik's Cube.
Ich hab mir gerade extra einen auf meiner Amazon-Liste fürs nächste Mal, wenn ich wieder was bestelle, gemacht, weil ich will auch mal wieder so einen haben.
Genau, also wer da aber sozusagen fortwährende Probleme hat, der kann sich auch dieses Projekt hier mal anschauen. Da hat nämlich jemand in einen Rubik's Cube einen Computer reingebaut mit Motor und dieser Rubik's Cube löst sich selber. Das heißt...
Und dreht, ja genau, zeig mal. Also, die Hörer können das Video jetzt natürlich nicht sehen.
Nee, aber im Prinzip legst du das Teil halt, der wird jetzt irgendwie verdreht und es sieht halt von außen aus wie ein ganz normaler Rubik's Cube. Und da ist halt Akku drin, da ist irgendwie ein Motor drin und der kann quasi alle Achsen selber bewegen und weiß halt auch genau, was...
Wie du gedreht hast, weil er sich's merkt.
Und kann sich halt selber lösen, dann legt er das Ding auf den Tisch und dann fängt er an, sich selber zu drehen von innen heraus.
Mach mal mit Sound.
Weiß nicht, ob der Sound dabei ist. Und marschiert dabei halt natürlich so über den Tisch rum und dreht sich gemächlich, nicht unbedingt in Rekordzeit, aber immerhin komplett autonom. Ja, also da haben sich Tesla noch was abgucken von. Der autonome Rubik's Cube. Queetscht so ein bisschen vor sich hin. Und fertig.
Das sieht er so, wie er zu sein hat. Ja, ist schon witzig.
Das ist wirklich ein sehr schönes Projekt. Ich freu mich, wie er den lädt. Vielleicht mit so einem Apple Watch-Connector oder so.
Ja, finde ich cool.
Das finde ich auch. Also was mir daran so gefällt, ist vieles. Also erstmal ist es natürlich rein ingenieursmäßig super. Und dann, das ist einfach toll. Ich empfinde gar keine Worte dafür, warum ich das so toll finde. Das ist einfach eine super Nummer, aber es beeindruckt alle. Und es ist auch eine coole Installation, weil die Leute werden natürlich immer wieder verdrehen und dann wird sich immer wieder selber lösen, solange bis der Akku ausgeht. Und wenn das Ding klug gebaut ist, dann legst du es halt auf den Tisch, wo gleich noch induktives Laden angesagt ist. Und dann bleibt er immer voll. Bleibt er immer voll.
Aber ist ein Einzelstück.
Naja, das ist halt so ein Projekt von so einem Nerd.
Naja, wenn er richtig cool ist, dann macht er das ja professionell und verkauft das. Also...
Ich weiß nicht. Sieht auf jeden Fall sehr 3D-geprintet aus, hier auch alles. Ziemlich sicher.
Wie gesagt, wenn man das professionell macht, wird das ja alles wahrscheinlich nochmal deutlich kleiner, deutlich leichter.
Unglaubliche Arbeit, ne? Guck dir mal allein dieses Wiring hier an.
Ja, und das ja auch an keiner Stelle so hakt, ne? Wenn er sich löst.
Ja, hier gibt's noch schöne Disassembly-Videos. Also, das könnt ihr euch mal alles in Ruhe anschauen. Ich wollte das nur mal erwähnen, weil das einfach so ein schöner... so ein schöner Hack ist. So, bevor hier das nächste Video wieder losläuft. Ach, ganz toll. Ganz, ganz, ganz toll ist das.
Nächst!
Versagt einem fast die Stimme vor lauter Begeisterung.
Oh Gott, wir springen hier so ein bisschen hinterher, aber das muss jetzt auch nochmal los werden. Ich bekam ja tatsächlich eine Mail von der Telekom, dass es jetzt schnelleres Internet gibt bei mir.
Super Vectoring nehme ich an.
Ja, was mich natürlich mega überrascht hat so. Weil man rechnet da ja bestenfalls alle 10 Jahre mit so einer Mail. Und jetzt ist es noch gar nicht so lange her, dass ich irgendwie das bekommen hab. Meine Begeisterung hielt sich aber auch schnell in Grenzen. Also ich bin hier rein zufällig jetzt in so einem Frühausbau. Also ich hab mal dann auf die Karte geguckt, wo das hier alles ist. Aber tatsächlich hier, dieses Haus, hat halt jetzt die Möglichkeit, Telekom V DSL Super Plus Plus irgendwie mit Bio-Kraftstoff zu bekommen. Und dann guck ich halt drauf und dann so, ja, hier 250 Megabit pro Sekunde. Und ich so, aha, mhm. War aber schon voller Skepsis. Und wie sich feststellte, auch zu Recht, natürlich immer noch nur mit 40 Megabit Upload.
Aber kann man noch anpassen lassen, oder? Da kann man das hin und her switchen, oder nicht?
Ja, theoretisch schon.
Aber bieten jetzt Produkt natürlich nicht an und so weiter.
Hätte man jetzt wirklich was draus machen können, so hätte man mal schick 100 100 draus machen können.
Hätte, hätte Fahrradkette.
Hätte, hätte Fahrradkette, hätte ich mir mal wieder ein bisschen Zeit gespart. Naja, und so ist es mir dann irgendwie die Extrakohle natürlich nicht wert, zumal ich ja dazu auch noch mal Geräte, Update im Routerbereich und so weiter auch noch mit finanzieren müsste. Ja, ach, ich weiß auch nicht, ob das nochmal was wird hier mit dem Internet.
In Deutschland.
Diese ganze Bandbreitenklage hier regelmäßig zu erheben, das nervt auch schon wieder langsam. Und es tut sich irgendwie nix. Keine Datenelche. Keine Datenkängurus. Ja, und die Debatte geht ja auch irgendwie nicht weiter. Man hat das Gefühl, dass irgendwas passiert ist.
Die Leute, die da irgendwie was zu sagen haben, schnallen doch überhaupt nicht, was das heißt, Telekommunikationsausbau voranzutreiben. Also ich hab das Gefühl, dass da Leute irgendwie sitzen, die...
Gewinnmaximierung betreiben.
Schadensminimierung oder was auch nicht so ganz genau.
Wir haben in der Politik halt häufig gar nicht aus diesem Bereich kommen, um zu wissen, was das so halt für Firmen zum Beispiel heißt, oder Leute, die sich halt selbstständig machen wollen und vielleicht eine Idee haben, wo sie einfach mal aufs Internet angewiesen sind, dass sie halt solchen Leuten Steine im Weg legen. Ich weiß nicht, ich find das halt arg frustrierend einfach nur noch.
Ja, ich meine, wenn du diese ganze Uhr, diesen Artikel 13-Uhr-Heber-Rechts-Schnösel-Dingsbumst an der EU anschaust, dann wird doch in Europa ja das Internet abgeschaltet, als ausgebaut irgendwie.
Lass mal so ganz nebenbei.
Ich hätte noch ein frustrierendes Thema, also weil wir schon dabei sind.
Wenn wir schon mal bei frustrierend sind, ne?
Genau.
So zum Abschluss, so zum Absacken.
Ja, damit wir noch mal alle so richtig, nein, so frustrierend ist das nicht, aber da ich ja jetzt dem Öfteren mich mit Servern beschäftigen muss und mich da so ein bisschen versucht hab reinzunurten, also Stack Overflow, wie mir gesagt wurde, ist das ja normal. Und ich hab halt jetzt irgendwie auf dem Server vorher immer, wenn ich Zertifikate gebraucht hab, Let's Encrypt genutzt und hat bei mir jetzt immer alles ganz gut funktioniert und das erste Auto-Renewal auch. Ich klopfe mal kurz auf den Tisch, hoffe, das nächste funktioniert auch ganz gut. Also bin ich echt zufrieden. Und da ich jetzt gerade in einer Hochschule in einem EU-Projekt sitze, war so die Idee, ja, lass halt mal so ein richtig shiny Zertifikat machen vom DFN oder was. Ich dachte mir halt am Anfang so, Ja, Let's Encrypt hat funktioniert, was soll schon schiefgehen, die oben machen wir. Erstmal so diesen Antragsgedöns, wo ich mir so durchgelesen hab, ja, okay, okay, okay, und dann irgendwie scheint, Ja, und Sie kommen bitte mit Ihrem Ausweis und mit diesem Formular dort und dorthin. Und ich mir auch dachte so, okay, ja, ist alles klar, gut. Der ist dann halt nicht über mich gelaufen, weil ich bin ja nur Mitarbeiter. Ich hab das dann meinem Chef übergeholfen und dachte mir so, Okay, dann setz ich mich jetzt hier mal hin. Wird ja bestimmt in einer Stunde erledigt sein. Und mach mal erst mal nur dieses Zertifikatsantragsgedöns und das DFN, also solche Forschungsnetzwerk, Netzwerksgemeinschaft, ich weiß nicht, wie die genau heißen, haben halt auch so eine Anleitung dafür. Und ich dachte mir halt so, ja, dann hältst du dich mal schön an die Anleitung.
Ich hab das auch schon mal gesehen.
Also ich dachte ja, dass die Anleitung irgendwie schwierig ist mit dem OpenSSL. Und dann sagen die dir halt auch so so Sachen wie, ja, du musst jetzt hier halt einen Private Public Key-Schlüssel generieren. Jo, Pass-Fras kann man machen. Und dann unten dran irgendwo so, ja, aber eigentlich, also das müsste man machen, um es ohne Pass-Fras zu haben. Aber das darf man auf gar keinen Fall irgendwo öffentlich, weil es muss ja geheim sein. Ich dachte ja, das ist mir jetzt klar. Aber dann nicht so darunter so, warum schlagt dir das überhaupt vor, dass es ohne Pass-Fras gelaufen ist? Also warum schlagt dir das überhaupt vor? Da war so null Information teilweise über diese Schritte, wo ich mir denke, das ist für jeden Admin, der das 24-7 wahrscheinlich macht, total klar und verständlich. Mir war dann halt so, ok, schön, erst mal hier mit Pass-Things eingegeben. Und irgendwann war dieser ganze Schmerz auch vorbei. Und ich dachte mir so, geil, jetzt habe ich diese Scheiße beantragt. Schlimmer kann es nicht werden. Mein Paypal-Konto aufgemacht, so gut, ok, noch genug Geld. Let's Encrypt aufgemacht, zack, Geld geschwendet. Ich dachte mir so, für den Hesse, den die mir hier drei Stunden nur für die Antragsstellung gemacht hat. Also ich weiß, Let's Encrypt ist natürlich nicht für alles perfekt. Aber ich meine, wenn du halt nur irgendwie so ein paar einfachere Projekte hast, wo es vielleicht einfach ausreicht. Ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel bei meiner Homepage auch nur ein Let's Encrypt-Zertifikat mir.
Was heißt nur? Das DFN ist halt einfach maximal bürokratisch. Das ist halt so...
Ja genau, aber vielleicht hat man einen Anwendungsfall, warum man... Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, warum man das will.
Also das Zertifikat, die Krypto, alles ist ja das Gleiche. Das ist nur, wer es quasi unterschrieben hat. Und ob du jetzt möchtest, dass du jetzt ganz offiziell von gewalter Stelle deinen Vertrauen ausgesprochen bekommen hast oder von so einer schmuddeligen Hackertruppe.
Jedenfalls, ich dachte mir so, okay, ich habe hier so lange mit diesem Scheiß zugebracht. Mal wieder, schlimmer kann es nicht werden.
Heute ist beim BSI das Zertifikat abgelaufen. Muss man... also bsi.bund.de Ja, irgendwie. Tolle D-Trust SSL Class 3 Blah, super, mega, sicher und abgelaufen.
2009.
Scheint doch mit MD5 Fingerprint.
RC4.
Ich sag mal so, als ich mich in dieses Open-SSL-Zertifikatsthema da im Club mal hab einführen lassen und da durchfräsen musste, das war auch alles ganz merkwürdig und kompliziert. Und dieses Open-SSL ist ein Universum für sich. Es kann alles. Und es kann mehr, als alles andere kann. die spezifischen Wünsche zu erfüllen, die man so hat, ist sehr schwierig teilweise, wenn man halt keine Ahnung davon hat. Und ja, muss man sich irgendwie halt durchfräsen, ist leider so. Aber dann kann man halt auch mit so, also dieses DFN zum Beispiel, ich hatte das auch mal in der UDK vorliegen und dachte mir, hole ich mir das Status-Zertifikat. Ich habe dann einfach Self-Sign-Certificates genommen, weil ich mir dachte, okay, also es war noch zu der Zeit, wo hatte die PS noch nicht so äh, na, required wurde oder geblässt wurde auch von den Browsern und ich habe dann einfach den Studenten gesagt, hier, das ist der Fingerprint, könnt da vertrauen, ist alles gut, ging dann erstmal so. Und jetzt benutze ich auch überall Let's Encrypt, zwar nicht mit Auto-Renewal für meine eigenen Sachen, da bin ich dann irgendwie doch immer noch zu eigen und kautzig, ich will die manuell, also ich mache es nicht vollständig manuell, aber es ist bei mir halt auch deswegen, weil das Let's Encrypt Ding läuft auf einem Server, den ich jetzt nicht, also an dem Projekt, das Projekt ist fertig.
Genau, und ich bin halt irgendwann auch nicht mehr da, das heißt, wenn das mal irgendwann, ich hoffe, dass es kaputt geht, wenn ich nicht mehr da bin. Nein, Quatsch, aber es ist halt so, wo ich mir dachte, ok Auto-Renewal und wenn es mal kaputt geht, dann muss ich halt jemand mal drum kümmern, weil es halt dann so und ich mein, das DFN hat ja irgendwie wirklich teilweise ausführliche Sachen geschrieben, dass man eben so dieses OpenSSL halt wieder mit einer Konfigurationsdatei befüttern kann. Und ich meinte ja großartig, dann gibst du hier nur einfach alles an. Dann funktionierte das aber nicht richtig, dann waren teilweise die DNS-Einträge nicht da, weil ich dachte mir so, boah ne. Ja, erstmal irgendwie, ok das erste Mal dann das Geld dahin gespendet, weil ich mir dachte so, danke, danke, danke, dass es auch einfacher geht, vor allen Dingen so viel unkomplizierter. Und ich habe halt echt nicht gedacht, dass diese Einpflegen des Zertifikates noch mal eine gleiche Scheiße ist. Ey, das ist ja der Wahnsinn. Da bekommst du deinen Zertifikatsrück, folgst wieder der Anleitung, du hast halt irgendwie mal einen, ja dein...
Kommt dann auch im falschen Format, ne?
Ne, die kam im richtigen Format, das Format war, also ich habe halt nGenX anlaufen auf dem Server, das funktionierte super. Du bekommst aber in der Anleitung gesagt, dass du deinen Private Key, deinen privaten Schlüssel brauchst. Ich so, ah, Private Key, alles klar, der Private Key, den man generiert hat. Eingepflegt, dann irgendwann auch die NGenX-Konfiguration gewusst und dann halt auch gesehen, dass man ja diese Zertifikatskette braucht, wo sie halt irgendwie auch erst schreiben, ja man braucht das Zertifikat, man braucht das Zertifikat und das, so weißt du, also man arbeitet Sachen von oben nach unten ab, hat schon alles runtergeladen, ach und übrigens, hier ist die gesamte Zertifikatskette.
Genau diese Schritte habe ich auch alle mal durchgemacht, ja.
Okay, dann ruhig bleiben, durchatmen, alles weiter konfiguriert, ähm, Engine X weiter konfiguriert, das erste Mal Engine X gestartet, Fehler, bam, nicht läuft, ist okay, dann gucken wir jetzt mal. Das erste war natürlich, dass er erstmal, weil ich ja den Password eingegeben habe, der wollte den natürlich haben, ist okay, alles klar. Entweder nimmst du den weg, oder machst dir ein Konfig-File, für eine der Sachen dann entschieden. Wieder ein Fehler, ist äh, okay, Fehler gegoogelt, ja, der MD5-Hash, also irgendwie der Hash funktionierte nicht, das sind zwei unterschiedliche Sachen, und du musst dir dieses Modulus und den, diesen Exponent anschauen. Ja, Exponent funktionierte, war dasselbe Wert, aber der Modulus nicht. Hä, aber das ist der Private Key, von dem die die ganze Zeit geredet haben. Okay, äh, weiß ich nicht. Ich hab dann halt wirklich lange getüftelt, hab unseren IT-Eller angeschrieben, ich so hier, sorry, aber ich komm bis zu der Stelle, und das scheint falsch zu sein. Und er so, ja, also wenn du hier deinen, den, den Private, äh, den, was hat er dann geschrieben, wenn du dann den erzeugten Schlüssel, äh, den du zum Signen, oder zum, zum Auftrag geben, in Auftrag geben des Zertifikats verloren hast, da ist ja furchtbar. Wenn ich so, ah, es geht überhaupt nicht um den Private Key, den man am Anfang erzeugt hat, sondern über dieses komische Ding, was du erzeugst, um das, den Zertifikatsantrag zum Laufen zu bekommen. Ja genau, so hab ich das Ding auch angeguckt. Also Huckel guckt grad ziemlich so skeptisch. Und genau, dann nutzt man halt nicht den Private Key, was in jeder Anleitung drin steht, sondern dieses komische Ding, was man generiert hat für den Zertifikatsrequest.
Eigentlich machst du einen Private Key. Und kannst damit ja dann den CSR... Nee, Moment, warte. Nee, du machst den CSR... Scheiße, jetzt komm ich auch gerade mit der Reihenfolge zusammen. Aber eigentlich hast du immer nur einen Private Key.
Ja, und du hast aber noch irgendwas, was du erstellst, was du abschickst an die Stelle.
Der Zertifikat-Signing-Request.
Genau, und jetzt bin ich mir auch nicht mehr sicher, aber ich hatte halt die falsche Kombination einfach nur genommen. Und er hat mir dann halt aber eine Info gesagt, wo ich dann wieder wusste, ja okay, das ist dann das andere. Und ich bin mir halt ziemlich sicher, dass es nicht der Private Key war, den man da eingegeben hat, sondern dieses Ding, das man gesigned hat, weil ich auf den Timestamp geguckt habe. Vielleicht liege ich da jetzt auch falsch, aber das war dann das erste, wo ich gemerkt habe, okay, geil, jetzt läuft es immerhin. Dann war aber das SSL immer noch so ein bisschen zerbröckelt. Und ich habe dann da gewisse so einen Analyzer, dass man dann halt gucken kann, an welcher Stelle es in deinem Zertifikat hakt. Das war irgendwas noch von OpenSSL, von Digital Ocean, das weiß ich nicht genau. Und das war dann lustig, weil da hatte ich ja diese Zertifikatskette aus der Anleitung drin. Und es war halt so, ja mein Zertifikat ist in Ordnung, die Zertifikatskette ist auch in Ordnung, aber die Verbindung von meinem Zertifikat zur Zertifikatskette hat nicht gepasst. Nochmal irgendwo durchgeguckt, ja, da muss man... Stimmt, das ist dann halt nicht diese Zertifikatskette, die in dieser Anleitung drin steht, sondern das ist diese Zertifikatskette, die irgendwo anders widerliegt.
Weil die sich zwischendurch wieder erneuert hat bestimmt und die im Tutorial noch die Alte verlinkt haben.
Genau, und ich hab dann halt auch extra dann geguckt, ob der von der Zertifikatskette, ob da einer heller passt zu dem Namen, weil man hat ja auch gesehen, von wo das ausgestellt wurde, was dann da als Name auch drin stand. Und das hat mich glaube ich immer so gefühlt 8 Stunden wahrscheinlich gekostet und ich dachte mir so, das sind hier so weiß ich wie viele Stunden ins Land gegangen für so Dinge.
Aber wenn es dann erstmal geht und dann wirft man SSL Labs an und dann kommt dann grünes A plus, dann ist man schon so, dann lädt man sich zurück und denkt sich so, nein.
Aber ich würde wetten mit dem DFN.
Wird dann nicht alles grün und ist nicht A plus.
Ja, das meiste ist ja Server-Config, aber ich habe gerade nochmal geguckt, weil ich habe einen Blogpost mal vor ewigen Zeiten geschrieben, wie man seine eigene Certificate-Authority aufsetzt, die natürlich nicht getrusted ist. Aber natürlich macht man das OpenSSL-Kommando, man sagt, mach mir einen neuen Key und mach mir einen Certificate Signing Request und dann kriegst sozusagen das Zertifikat passend zu deinem Key.
Okay, dann habe ich das wahrscheinlich jetzt umgedreht, aber ja, das war aber so eine Info, die ich mir dann irgendwie weitergeholfen habe. Ich dachte so, oh man, es ist einfach so ein krasser Hässel und dann musstest du natürlich auch noch dein NGINX nochmal ein bisschen umkonfigurieren.
Oder gibt es auch schöne NGINX-Optionen, um deinen SSL-Verkehr zu optimieren. Die kann ich dir mal abseits von diesem Podcast nochmal rüberpasten. Denn da gibt es so einige Optionen, um das noch flutschiger zu machen.
Oh, sehr gerne. Das war halt so fünf Minuten vor Release. Ich hatte dann auch nochmal geguckt in der NGINX-Config direkt wegen Komprimierungssachen. Da hatte ich auch kurz eine Konfiguration drin und da funktionierte halt beim NGINX nur noch die Willkommen bei NGINX, aber halt nicht mehr die eigentliche Seite, auf die ich wollte. Und dann habe ich dann halt gesagt, okay, nochmal rückgängig machen, so diese Standard, diese Sachen, reicht erstmal und ich fasse es erstmal nicht mehr an.
Zu diesem Thema gibt es übrigens eine schöne URL. Ich hoffe, die ist auch immer noch aktuell. Ich gehe jetzt erstmal davon aus. Und zwar sind dafür die gängigen, kannst du das vielleicht mal aufmachen, Browser. Gibt es für die gängigen Server-Applikationen die aktuellen Settings, welche Algorithmen wie zu konfigurieren und auszuschalten und aktivieren sind. Und hier siehst du auch zum Beispiel bei Engine X, wenn du noch mal kurz hoch scrollst. Da sind dann nämlich auch schon mal ganz viele von diesen Settings drin. Und ich bilde ihm ein, die hatten dann auch sowas wie für Postfix und so, also nicht nur für Web-Browser. Haben die jetzt nur noch? Nee, die haben unten drunter. Genau, da ist dann halt auch wirklich so Web, Quatsch-Mail-Server, HAProxy benutze ich auch. Und so ein paar andere Tools. Das ist... Ja, das ist immer ganz gut. Weil sonst, wenn man sich das alles so über Stack-Overflow zusammensammelt oder so, dann sind...
Dann sind wir nicht durch.
Genau, und dann haben wir halt alle auch nicht immer die ganze Wahrheit und dann...
Oder nur eine sehr alte Wahrheit.
Ja, oder eine alte Wahrheit, genau. Ich müsste mal gucken, steht hier irgendwann, wann das das letzte Mal aktualisiert wurde, weil ich will jetzt natürlich auch nicht...
Alter, diese TLS-Scheiße, das ist wirklich echt das Schlimmste.
Ja, aber es gibt ja nichts Besseres.
Nein, ich meine diese Scheiße, die man am Hacken hat, wenn man sich damit beschäftigen muss, weil diese ganze Konfiguration, ich meine, wer blickt da durch mit welches Hifer jetzt gerade aktuell sind oder wieder verbraten sind und allein die Terminologie da klarzukriegen, wo da oben und unten ist, das ist...
Sagen wir mal so, es ist schon sehr, äh, komplex, aber nichtsdestotrotz würde ich sagen, irgendwie man sollte sich schon damit auskennen.
Ja, ich habe auch nichts dagegen. So ein Angebot ist natürlich total mega super. Ich stelle nur in dem Moment gerade wieder fest, was das für ein Stress ist, wenn man sich damit wirklich selber rumschlagen sollte.
Ja, vor allen Dingen, ich... Also ich frage mich halt auch immer so... Also ich möchte halt mir zum Beispiel nicht einen eigenen Server grad ans Bein binden, der mein Letty-Server ist, mit Mail und so ein Gedöns drauf, weil ich mir halt denke so, boah, nee ey, davor hab ich so einfach so eine Angst vor meinem Admin-Schwer... Also wenig Admin-Fähigkeit.
Ja du, aber wenn du davon so zurückschrickst, werden die auch nicht besser. Also so ein Freebies-Server mit ZFS, immer bevor du irgendwas machst, einen Snapshot gemacht, dauert eine halbe Sekunde oder weniger und dann kannst du da rumgurken, wie du lustig bist und wenn es schief geht, dann loggst du dich mit der Recovery-Konsole ein, machst ZFS Rollback und fängst dann voran. Also ich hab tatsächlich, seit ich ZFS auf dem Server hab, immer wenn ich mir bei bestimmten Dingen so nicht so ganz so sicher war, Snapshot gemacht und ich musste selten darauf zurückgreifen, aber wenn, dann super. Ja und am Ende des Tages, also Mail-Server sage ich ja immer wieder, ist ja so ein bisschen die Königsdisziplin, weil da einfach so viele Komponenten zusammenspielen und damit dein Mail-Server nicht sofort als Spam-Schleuder gilt und du überhaupt irgendeine Mail irgendwo durchkriegst dieser Tage und so. Das ist echt so ein eigenes Reich, aber einen Web-Server laufen lassen selber, easy peasy, wirklich super easy peasy. Kannst auch gerne einen Jail bei mir auf dem Server haben, ist noch Platz, hat noch drei Pie.
Wartet nicht, richtige Hacker haben nicht Jails, die haben richtig auf Iron.
Wir sollen hier nicht richtige Hacker sagen, da wird wieder Mimimi gemacht.
Achso, ja, ich hab kürzlich verschiedene schlecht klingende Podcasts gehört. Wo einfach das Schlechtklingen gar nicht mal unbedingt nur von dem Quellmaterial kommt, sondern auch teilweise des unklaren Post-Processing-Prozesses. Zum Beispiel wurden dann so in dem einen Fall die Mixe erstellt und teilweise auch relativ krass, also für mich schon zu krass. Post-Processing zum Beispiel, dass du das Gate halt die ganze Zeit hörst, wie es den Noise aus und an macht und so. Oder sehr die hohen Mitten betont, dass die S-Lauten schon sehr in mein Ohr schneiden waren. Und dann wurde das bei Podgy hochgeladen und die jagen das ja auch noch mal durch Auphonic durch. Und dann kommt dieser Stereo-Mix durch Auphonic durch und Auphonic braucht halt auch irgendwie so ein sinnvolles Quellmaterial, um das noch besser zu machen, sonst macht deren Kompression und Limiting die Probleme noch lauter und alles ganz wirr. Naja, und dann gab es bei der Aufnahme selbst auch hier und da Probleme und irgendwie habe ich dann das hier und da auch mal angemerkt und dachte mir, okay, ist ja immer das eine so kritisieren und dann sollte man ja auch noch Verbesserungsvorschläge anbieten. Das habe ich dann vor Ort zwar auch gemacht, aber dachte mir, mit meinem ganzen Audio gebastel und so, was ich die letzten Jahre betrieben habe und die Pritlove-Podcast-Schule am eigenen Leib erlebt habe, da schreibe ich das noch mal alles nieder und zwar in Englisch, weil es gibt ja zum Beispiel im Sendegate, gibt es ja auch tatsächlich, also in dieser Community, super viele Infos, aber sehr viel halt auch nur in Deutsch. Genau, und deswegen dachte ich mir, okay, ich packe das jetzt mal in meinen Blog in Englisch. Da ist natürlich auch längst nicht alles drin, aber ich dachte mal, ich arbeite mal so die grundlegenden Sachen ab, die man, also wenn man die beachtet, relativ einfach eine gute Aufnahme hinbekommt und vielleicht die üblichen Probleme, wenn man nichts weiß, vermeiden kann. Genau, und das hatte ich auch schon mal getwittert, aber falls das euch trotzdem interessiert, ist der Link schon im Chat. Ne, mach ich den noch mal im Chat. Und es sind auch Sachen, die nicht nur für Podcast gelten. Das sind auch einfach generelle Tipps. Also kann man sich auch so mal zu Gemüte führen. Wobei das Allerwichtigste wirklich gleich am Anfang steht, nämlich dass an der Quelle am meisten Hebelweg vorhanden ist, um...
Ja, was am Anfang schon scheiße ist, das wird dann später nicht besser. Genau, also man kann das eine oder andere retten, aber eigentlich das Wenigste. Also ich hab mir das Ding ja heute nochmal ausführlicher ein bisschen durchgelesen. Ich finde, du kannst da nochmal ein paar Grafik hinzufügen, insbesondere was so diese Funktionsprinzipien betreuen. Meine Kanal ist im Prinzip beliebig aus, weil ich hab das auch schon mal geschrieben, für irgendeinen Workshop schon ewig her. Hat sich auch eigentlich gar nicht so viel dran geändert, weil was glaube ich die wenigsten begreifen ist, wie viel der Raum eigentlich schon ausmacht. Also ich bin auch mal wieder erschüttert. Bei so manchen Aufnahmen, auch Podcasts, die auch teilweise schon so ein bisschen erfolgreicher sind. Und dann sitzt dann doch mal wieder einer in irgendeinem halligen Raum. Klar, dann ist so die Einstellung so, ja, ging grad nicht anders, ich war grad da und so. Und das ist mir auch schon mal passiert und lässt sich auch nicht immer komplett verhindern. Aber man muss das dann halt auch schon so ein bisschen wollen, finde ich so. Und wenn man es so will, dann geht halt eigentlich auch immer irgendwas, irgendwas geht immer.
Ja, ich hab ja auch so ein paar Sachen da reingeschrieben, weil ich hab auch ein relativ großes Zimmer und da jetzt mittlerweile hab ich relativ viele Akustik-Panele schon an der Wand, das geht's. Aber früher hab ich dann halt auch Mikrofon-Ständer hier so mit quasi den Armen quer, also horizontal und dann so Decken drüber gehangen und mich damit umzingelt. Irgendwas geht immer. Oder man kann sich vor einen offenen Kleiderschrank setzen, das ist auch super. Der schluckt einfach.
Ja, oder wenn man so eine große Wand hat und einfach gar nichts weiß, was man machen soll, einfach Molltorn ranhängen, gibt's auch in verschiedenen Farben. Oder was bei mir immer wieder der Königsweg ist, ich hab das ja auch im Studio noch nicht in der Menge, wie ich es gerne hätte, einfach schönes Bild aussuchen, was man sowieso an der Wand haben will, das druckt man sich über so einen Service einfach auf Leinwand aus. Gibt's ja heutzutage alles in viel und günstig. Und teilweise machen die das auch explizit, um es auf so einem Rahmen aufzuziehen. Und man kann dann einen Rahmen auch gleich anliefern. Kauft man sich einfach Lattenholz, 5 cm Durchmesser, baut sich daraus den Rahmen und packt dann hinten einfach Basotec von der Resterampe rein. Das gibt es auf Ebay immer sehr günstig, immer so Basotec für Schnittreste, gibt man da so säckeweise für vergleichsweise wenig Geld, also im Vergleich zu was das so in normalen Schnittblöcken kostet. Da ist es ja ordentlich teuer. Und dann stopft man sich einfach die Versatzstücke da hinten rein, befestigt das irgendwie halbwegs und hat ein schönes Bild an der Wand und das fängt schon mal ordentlich. Was mich immer wieder total irre macht. Ich bin ja immer so viel unterwegs und nehme Podcasts vor Ort auf, insbesondere in so weniger Firmen, aber halt so größeren Organisationen, Unis, halt wo viele Leute arbeiten. Und nicht selten läuft es dann darauf hinaus, dass man in so einem Besprechungsraum landet. Und das finde ich so abenteuerlich, dass also auch in neuen Gebäuden, die so in den letzten zehn Jahren gebaut wurden, die Besprechungsräume dann immer so kacknackte, kalte, am besten noch mit, weil muss ja transparent sein, Glas umkringt und dann setzen die Leute da rein. Und also bei mir ist es mittlerweile extrem. Also ich leide da, glaube ich, mehr darunter als normalerweise Leute. Aber jeder leidet darunter und viele merken es einfach gar nicht, dass dieses Echo und dieser Hall, der da ist, weil einfach überall nur nackte Wände und eben noch schlimmer Glas sind, da kann man sich doch gar nicht unterhalten. Das verstehe ich überhaupt nicht. Und die geben einen Shitload von Geld für so ein Haus aus, das kostet alles aber Millionen und dann für so diese drei oder vier bekackten Konferenzräume, wo es wirklich echt nicht mehr aufs Geld ankommt, sparen die sich dann die 2000 Euro, um da einfach mal ordentlich einen Schallschutz reinzumachen oder den einfach von vornherein schon so zu bauen.
Was halt echt ganz spannend ist, ich habe gerade mit dem Potsdamer Institut für Klimafolgenforschung zu tun und die haben ja ein relativ großes Areal auf dem Telegrafenberg in Potsdam. Die haben sich ein Haus bauen lassen, an dem sie nichts im Innenraum verändern dürfen. Die haben vom Architekten eine Vorgabe, was die in den Zimmern zu stehen haben, was da nicht rein darf, wie viele Bücher da drin sind. Das muss man sich mal vorstellen. Keine Ahnung, was da dem Typen eingefallen ist. Ja, das musst du dir mal vorstellen.
Wie nicht dürfen.
Ja, die dürfen das nicht, weil, also wahrscheinlich Urheberrecht und rechtliche Schritte würde der Architekt vorgehen. Ja, das ist richtig krass. Die dürfen keinen Poster angewenden hängen.
Den würde ich doch zum Lokaltermin einladen. Erstmal einen ordentlichen Tritt in die Eier geben.
Oder in so einen Raum stecken und dann irgendwie Motorhead auf.
Modern Talking. 24 Stunden.
Aber bei VUGA zum Beispiel.
Und schön an den Sitz festhalten, immer so mit Tropfen in die Augen, weit aufgerissen und dann...
Bei VUGA in einer Backfabrik, das steht ja unter Denkmalschutz, und da war ja viel im Innenraum auch gefliest. Und da waren so die ersten Innenraumkonzepte so, dass die Besprechungsräume immer an den Außenwänden waren, die natürlich gefliest waren. Und gefliesste Wände mit Glasfront. Das ist die absolute Hölle. Die Sprachverständlichkeit war wirklich... Close, also fast null auf jeden Fall. Und ich saß auch immer die ganze Zeit so da, hier sind zehn Leute im Raum, die gerade sich so irgendwie untereinander unterhalten. Man versteht null, nichts, gar nichts. Und es geht immer nur, wenn einer spricht, und dann muss man sich aber auch richtig Mühe geben. Und dann haben aber glücklicherweise genug Leute gemerkt, dass das relativ scheiße ist. Und dann haben sie so einen, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie die Firma hieß, aber so einen Innenarchitekturbüro, die sich eben so mit Klanggestaltung quasi des Innenraums beschäftigt haben. Und die haben eine relativ kreative Lösung gefunden, weil das steht natürlich auch alles unter Denkmalschutz. Dann hatten die da so Dinge, die man so an, wie sagt man, diese Durch-, so Angelleine quasi, wie heißt das so, durchsichtige Plastik-Dingsbumms. Also so irgendwelche weißen Schaumstoffdinger, die auch so an strategischen Positionen so in den Raum gehangen haben zum Beispiel, die auch relativ leicht waren so. Und das hat so viel gebracht. Und das hat wahrscheinlich am Ende, ich meine, das Büro hat wahrscheinlich ein bisschen Geld für Personal verlangt, aber die Materialien waren relativ überschaubar. Und das hat so viel verbessert. Und das ist halt auch genau so für diese Podcast-Aufnahmesituation. Es braucht gar nicht so viel, aber man muss sich erstens dessen bewusst sein, dass es überhaupt ein Problem gibt. Und das Beste ist echt einmal so klatschen oder schnippen. Und wenn man genau hinhört, dann hört man halt dieses SIRR, was dann zum Beispiel so hinten rankommt oder den Hall oder das Echo.
Also bei mir zu Hause, weil ich ja Dielen habe, habe ich irgendwann einen Teppich von Oma geerbt. Und seitdem war Akustik auch deutlich besser.
Ja, aber es sind halt eben genau diese hohen Frequenzen, die so extrem stören oder das Extrem spürbar machen. Die Tiefenfrequenzen sind in allen Räumen, in allen kleineren Räumen Problem. Die kriegt man auch nicht mit Schaumstoff oder anderen leichten Materialien kontrolliert.
Man kann schon so Bassfänger in die Ecke packen, aber dann...
Ja, aber einfach... Ja, genau. Das, was am meisten stört, ist auch am einfachsten zu fixen, sagen wir mal. Oder da kann man relativ viel verbessern mit wenig Aufwand.
Also hier noch mal Revolutionsauftrag an all die Leute, die in ihren Berufsumgebungen genau in so einer Situation sind, wie ich sie gerade beschrieben habe. Und ich bin mir sicher, da gibt es eine Menge davon. Und vielleicht ist das euch auch selber noch gar nicht aufgefallen. Vielleicht gehört ihr auch schon zu der aufgeklärten Masse, die das Licht gesehen hat und die weiß, wo das Problem ist. Das ist einfach... Meetings nerven sowieso. Die meisten Meetings sind einfach überflüssig und scheiße. Aber sich dann auch noch da zwei Stunden irgendwie rumtrollen zu müssen, und dann wird man auch noch so akustisch gefoltert. Danach ist man ja vollkommen alle so. Und man weiß auch gar nicht, warum eigentlich. Aber vielleicht düngt es euch, dass es einfach daran liegen kann, dass die Akustik da schlecht ist. Und wenn man da einfach mal druckt euch eure Lieblings-Icons von euren Programmen aus, irgendwie die haben alle genug Pixel, das ist eine Top-Vorlage, macht euch da so ein Meter mal ein Meter Ausdrucke. Das ist alles mit wenig Geld zu bezahlen. Dachlatte gibt es irgendwie im Baumarkt für wenig Geld. Fünf Zentimeter Durchmesser ist schnell mit ein paar Spacks zusammengeschraubt. Leinwand rumgestülpt, fertig ist der Rahmen. Dann hängt ja die Dinger auf, sieht schick aus, könnt ihr auch am laufenden Meter austauschen, irgendwie App-Icon of the Day oder sonst irgendwas. Oder baut da irgendwie Meme draus oder Tetris oder hängt euch was aus. Hängt einfach diese Dinger an die Wand und ihr werdet euch wundern, wie unfassbar anders das ist. Und Spezialtipp, wenn an den Wänden nichts geht, wie ich das hier in der Mitte eben nämlich gemacht hab, das hat es nämlich vollgebracht. Ich hab die teuren, also die sind nicht billig, aber lohnt sich. Ein Meter mal ein Meter mal fünf Zentimeter Basotec. Das ist so eigentlich so das Standardmaß, was man so haben will. Gibt es bei Thomann für billiger als woanders. Und die macht man einfach mit ein paar Tropfen Kleber einfach an die Decke. Wenn ihr da so eine Decke habt, wo sonst nichts weiter ist, sondern einfach nur so typischer Altbau-Scheiß fünf Meter hoch und es heilt bis zum Getno und die Wände sind in irgendeiner Form heilig und man kann da nichts ranhängen oder da müssen Dinge stehen oder Beamer oder was auch immer. Ja und Fenster kommt ihr nicht ran und Gradinen sind schwierig. Ballert einfach diesen Kack oben da dran. Das bringt so viel, das ist echt Tag und Nacht.
Es gibt auch Stellwände, die man, wenn man halt bewegen kann und dann, wenn es drauf ankommt, halt nur an die strategischen Stellen mal hinschieben kann.
Und was mir auch noch einfällt in dem Zusammenhang, da kommen wir wieder an den Anfang, dieses Problem mit Meeting-Raum in Großbüro, wo so Tische sind, wo dann Leute Meetings halten, während ein paar Meter weiter andere Leute versuchen zu arbeiten. Da ist jetzt nicht heil so sehr das Problem, aber man kann sich eigentlich auch nicht so richtig konzentrieren und man ist dann irgendwie auch automatisch laut oder man muss dann aber leiser reden, als man eigentlich will und es ist auch unangenehm, also nichts passt so richtig. Baut euch da so eine Podcast-Situation hin. Baut euch da fünf Headset hin. Ja, hat auch den Vorteil, dass man nebenbei solche Gespräche auch sehr effizient aufnehmen kann, so zu Dokumentationszwecken. Und vor allem, man redet dann einfach nur über Kopfhörer miteinander. Dann redet man automatisch leise, man muss gar nicht so schreien, man belästigt die anderen Leute nicht so.
Vor allem muss man sich eigentlich auch gar nicht mehr treffen, sondern kann das gleich auch im Rechner rauskommen.
Ja, du kannst auch Videos einspielen, ohne dass es irgendwie andere Leute groß belästigt. Und das ist auch schnell gemacht. Ein paar Headset, die was taugen, zahlt, zahlt, was weiß ich, du nimmst mal 2000 Euro in die Hand und dann hast du aber so eine Situation. So ein Kopfhörer-Verstärker und ein 8-Port-Audio-Interface ist ja alles nix. So ein kleiner Mixer hier, dieser Zoom L12 reicht vollkommen raus. Und schon hast du so eine Besprechungssituation für 5, 6 Leute wunderbar zusammen. So und alle sind glücklich. Amen.
Ja, also genau, da sind ein paar weitere so Sachen noch mit drin und ich habe auch dann gedacht, okay, jetzt muss ich doch noch ein bisschen abnerden. Also es ist auch noch ein bisschen ein technisches Detail drin, was hoffentlich nicht vollkommen falsch ist, aber ich habe schon jetzt ein paar andere Leute drüberlesen lassen und die meinten, nee, nee, passt schon. Genau.
Ich habe letztens nämlich auch irgendwie einen Podcast aus meiner Liste gekickt, weil ich fand das so furchtbar, wenn die Aufnahmen einfach kontinuierlich schlecht bleiben oder dann sowas wie, dann machen die schon eine Schaltung über Skype und dann hast du halt nicht irgendwie, scheinbar wurde nicht auf zwei Spuren aufgenommen, sondern du hast die Ruckelgeräusche hier von Skype irgendwie noch drin. Wo ich sag so, oh sorry ey, du hast ein Budget scheinbar, weil dir ständig irgendwelche Leute Sponsoring geben und dann sowas drin zu haben, finde ich, ist halt echt so.
Also ja, gerade in der heutigen Zeit Podcasts müssen nicht scheiße klingen. Also selbst mit billigsten Mitteln, selbst wenn man kaum Budget für Technik hat, aber ein Audiointerface kostet irgendwie fast nichts, was taugt. Man kann irgendwie, wenn man sich bei den Mikrofonen so ein bisschen Mühe gibt, irgendwie auch relativ günstig noch davon kommen mit ordentlichem Klang, aber ja genau, dieses Drumherum, das ist eigentlich das was zählt. Und so ein Bewusstsein einfach, also überhaupt schon mal das Bewusstsein dafür haben. Und das fehlt wahrscheinlich ja schon bei den meisten, dass gar nicht der Unterschied gehört wird, dass manche Podcasts gut klingen und manche nicht so gut und so. Ich frage mich auch, inwieweit das an der Abhörsituation liegt. Ob halt, wenn die Leute wirklich so mit den schlimmsten in-ear oder was weiß ich, Mini-Kopfhörern, irgendwelches Audio konsumieren, dass sie dann überhaupt sowieso den Unterschied gar nicht merken. Aber wenn ich zum Beispiel natürlich auf meinen Monitor- laussprechern oder Kopfhörern dann so schlechte Aufnahmen höre, dann ist das richtig so...
Ich meine, ich höre halt viel Podcasts über in-ear oder ich lass das Telefon laut laufen. Und also es gibt wirklich viele Sachen, wenn es so einen Hall hat, ja, mittlerweile höre ich das ein bisschen drüber hinweg, deswegen deaboniere ich nicht. Aber eben so dieses Skype-Geräusche, wo dann noch dieses Grrrr, wo ich da, ey, sorry, ey, das, das, da bin ich ja, nee, da habe ich kein Verständnis dafür. Und das Lustige ist, weil du sagtest, in einem Kleiderschrank aufnehmen, ich weiß gar nicht.
Vor einem Kleiderschrank?
Ja, oder vor, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich den richtig verstanden habe. In einem meiner Podcasts, die ich höre, da meint ihr also, ja, nee, ich sitze halt gerade im Kleiderschrank, das war halt so geil.
Es ist eine super Location, um keinen Hals ab. Man muss auch dazu sagen, falls ihr nicht drum rumkommt, mal einen Podcast aufzunehmen, wo Hall drin vorkommt, es gibt tatsächlich auch einigermaßen brauchbare D-Verb Plugins, die kosten nicht so unglaublich viel Geld. Leider habe ich jetzt hier auf meinem Laptop die nicht installiert, deswegen fallen mir gerade die Namen nicht ein. Aber wenn ihr so ein bisschen sucht, werdet ihr schon irgendwelche Reviews und Artikel finden, die dann die besten Lobpreisen, die kosten dann meistens so, weiß nicht, 30, 40 Dollar. Und mit denen kriegt man schon das Schlimmste an diesem Hall weg. Aber was ich auch in dem Post geschrieben hab, dieses Post-Processing sollte man so machen, dass es halt die Soundqualität verbessert, ohne dass der Hörer merkt, dass da massiv gerade am Audio geschraubt wurde. Und auch bei so D-Verb, D-Essern, bei Kompressoren, bei Gates, sobald man das irgendwie ein bisschen zu weit dreht, dann hört man den Effekt und das macht mich dann noch wahnsinniger, wie eben dieses angesprochene Gate, wo man hört im Signal irgendwie so einen Grundnoise, der einfach da ist, so im Hintergrund, der nicht anderweitig rausgefiltert wurde. Und immer wenn derjenige dann aufhört zu sprechen, dann ist halt dieses Rauschen weg, dann kommt es wieder voll rein, weil es halt wahrscheinlich hochkomprimiert wurde bis zum Abwinken. Oh, werde ich wahnsinnig! Oder das Allerschlimmste ist, wenn das Gate zumacht, bevor das Wort zu enden ist oder die Silbe, das veröffentlichen Leute, da kann ich echt die Wand hochgehen. Hört ihr euch das nicht selber an? Da sind Worte nicht fertig bevor.
Ja, vor allem, also ich finde das dann halt, man kann das, finde ich, Leuten verzeihen, die irgendwie kaum, also die kein Geld dafür nehmen, also so offensichtliches Werbegedöns drin haben, aber wenn das eben irgendwelche Leute sind, die von anderen Unternehmen so Werbefeatures dann auch noch im Podcast haben. Sorry, ihr solltet dann eigentlich auf jeden Fall das Geld haben, um da mal entweder, wenn man es nicht selber kann, jemandem das machen zu lassen oder aber sich mal die fünf Minuten Zeit nehmen und sich damit zu beschäftigen.
Ja, wobei in den Fällen jetzt zuletzt war es so, dass die Leute sogar richtig geiles Equipment hatten. Also Geld für Equipment war da nur das Gehör nicht oder das Verständnis oder das Auseinandersetzen mit wie mache ich das jetzt eigentlich oder dann halt in einem super halligen Raum aufgenommen.
Die Frage ist vielleicht auch so, bekommst du dann halt auch das Feedback von also ich meine jetzt einfach zu sagen, die Leute zu kritisieren, bekommen sie denn überhaupt von ihren Hörern das Feedback, dass sie das selber überhaupt mitbekommen, dass es vielleicht doof klingt, wenn sie schon selber nicht hören. Das ist ja auch nochmal eine Frage.
Ja, wie gesagt, da frage ich mich auch immer, inwieweit jetzt mein, durch die letzten Jahre so ins Audiothema Rheinlöden geschulten Ohren jetzt auch so übermäßig sensitiv sind. Das kann ich jetzt natürlich selber nicht beantworten. Ich habe den Eindruck, dass die breite Masse nicht so sensitiv ist, aber nichtsdestotrotz kann man sich ja Mühe geben.
Die breite Masse ist vor allem breit.
Oh yeah, ich bin auch jetzt hier ganz schön ausgebreitet.
Ich denke, wir können jetzt hier auch einen Punkt setzen.
Wir haben jetzt genug Pimp-Vorlagen geliefert.
Genau, absolut. Und von daher...
Wenn es wedert auch nur noch und sagt nichts mehr.
Genau. Ja, gibt es noch irgendwas Wichtiges? Ja, ich bedanke mich nochmal bei all denen, die in diesem Monat bei den Daueraufträgen für die Mitter-Ebene dazu gestoßen sind. Keep it coming.
Eine Sache hab ich noch. Zwar hab ich heute ein Paket bekommen von Happy Coffee. Mit irgendwie total...
Hipster-Coffee.
Geilen Filter-Coffee, Bohnen, Zeugs. Ich weiß aber nicht wieso, weil ich bin ja kein Kaffeetrinker. Jetzt frag ich mich, ob das ein Hörer war, der mir was Gutes tun wollte. In dem Fall würde ich vielleicht jemand anderem aus der Freak Show weitergeben.
Deine Adresse ist doch hier gar nicht publiziert.
Nee, aber wenn man meine Smug-Domain... Ah, verstehe. Dann, ja. Also keine Ahnung, wo das herkommt. Falls das ein Hörer war, bitte noch mal auf Twitter melden. Ansonsten gehe ich davon aus, dass der Kaffee vergiftet ist.
An irgendeinem Opfer, was unwichtig ist, quasi ob er vergiftet ist.
An Letty zum Beispiel.
Ich will das jetzt gar nicht weiter in die Länge ziehen, nur da das ohne Kommentar und ohne Botschaft im Paket kam.
Es kam gerade im Chat noch ein schöner Link hier zu so einer...
Die ist cool...
.VBG, gesetzliche Unfallversicherung, Akustik im Bürofibel, irgendwie dickes PDF mit vielen guten Tipps. Da findet man viel wieder mit in schön und teuer, was man alles so machen kann im Büro. Ach das! Rettet eure Ohren, ihr rettet damit eure... Sanity, genau.
Aber es muss, wie gesagt, auch gar nicht wirklich...
Anderer Tipp ist natürlich auch Meetings vermeiden. Einfach nicht hingehen. Und wenn ihr nicht wisst, wie man da rangehen soll, Office Space gucken. Das spart euch noch mehr Meetings. So, jetzt aber... Neue Ende, ne? Das war's. Leute, Freak Show 223 ist abgefeiert. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, fürs Unterstützen, fürs nächstes Mal wieder einschalten, fürs Weitersagen, fürs Loben, fürs Kritisieren, Kommentieren und überhaupt alles.